this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
hello hello hello and welcome to well a
bleak gray overcast cool morning here in
South Africa is bartha's kind of cold as
it's been in a while so hopefully it
will warm up a little bit later as the
cards separate and hopefully a little
bit of sunshine will come out at some
point the cloud doesn't look too thick
so I think the Sun should come out at
some time now my name is Justin on
camera I've got a sins oh there we go
answer sins oh saying good morning it is
a very very very warm welcome to all of
you and I hope that you are going to
interact with us lots this morning
hashtag Safari live on Twitter or
YouTube chat now the plan is for the
morning one is that we've got Brent Leo
Smith mended and seems to be that he is
feeling better so he's going to be back
up with us we're also going to have
Steve on walk but for us we gonna check
all the wastes in signs of Juma I'm
gonna try and see if we can find any
sign for him community shadaloo or even
see if maybe then kuma pride push back
further waste again interestingly enough
I believe Steve had a very exciting
sighting of the Akuma practiced after we
finished the show last night so I'm
gonna leave that for him to tell you all
about cause he sounds like he had a
really cool time with him good now we're
on filler ones at the moment no sign of
anything we had a bit of rain last night
that unfortunately has probably washed
away 90% of the tracks that we're going
to be looking for this morning I don't
even remember what time it was but the
rain came in it must have been early
hours of this morning and it didn't rain
for long but it seemed to rain with a
little bit of force and so now seeing
tracks is almost impossible at the
moment so we're gonna try and see if I
can find them just trying get a bit of
lights on the situation it is quite dark
this morning it's not very kind of good
for tracking it's the sort of lights is
not incredibly sort of bright sand and
that makes tracking a little harder so
just trying to look as we go but this is
a road yesterday that was covered in
Lion tracks now today you can't see a
single Lion track on its because of that
rain hello impala sorry I didn't even
see you there you were lying down in the
grass luckily it wasn't a lion or a
leopard or I might have missed it
completely it's time to wake up to some
come on
so here is a male Impala that was having
a bit of a nap on the grass itself and
they sleep a lot on this fire break area
we see them regularly on for the monster
plant just because it's a bit more open
and it's easier for them to see what's
going on good now I believe Brent is up
and about and like I say he is feeling
better so let's go across him and see
how he's doing
yes welcome welcome I'm feeling much
better you nearly got to see what I had
for lunch yesterday on Drive but I have
recovered and we've got that lovely
little cagey dude who's been catching a
ride he just landed on the car good
morning my name is Brittany Smith and I
have the Batman on camera and I love
katydids
unless they're in my room because they
have the ability to create the most
incredible screams or look he's cleaning
his foot I'm gonna try get him onto the
dashboard so it's easier for Craig
because I move around too much and it's
a female katydid and she lifts up you
can see her ovipositor egg-laying device
where she's tucked it up now but a
female katydid now they can create some
of the most incredible noises by rubbing
their legs the back legs together it is
incredibly loud and often when they tend
to do that there happen to be in the
highest corner of the roof and now this
patina your feet again you can see
there's very very powerful and big back
legs it looks like she might even be
getting ready for a leap into the abyss
off the car now most of the Katie
katydid species is the opposite to
grasshoppers are nocturnal
and so she's obviously was flying
somewhere after a night out on the
bushes feeding away I'm just trying to
see come on now
yep so you can see those feet are very
very important for her so she likes to
keep all her feet clean and also with
his saliva I'll add a bit of stickiness
so when she needs to grip on to
something so what she's gonna try to do
is find a nice green patch during the
day and what to hide up on and look how
incredibly long her antennae are now
there's antennae offered various
different reasons and a lot of it is to
pick up possible predators also to pick
up possible mates so very very cool
little insect kalenna you are spot on
the noise is a to attract mates and it's
normally the males that make more noise
than the females to attract them and in
some species the females will have
longer antennae to a toothpick up where
that the male's are I've just noticed
I've been looking for this ever since I
arrived back from in the sabi sands so
I'm going to have a quick look because
there's a I haven't seen many of them
this year the African vagrant butterfly
and their little caterpillar larval
stage is one of my favorites because
they've got awesome awesome coloration
but also they're their defense
mechanisms are are so so wonderful that
their body feels like sandpaper and they
seem to really like this exotic plant
that grows here so this is not a this is
called a peanut butter cassia and
actually comes from South America but I
just noticed that this one has been
heavily fed on by caterpillars and I'm
hoping that there might be I think I
might be a bit late I was hoping that
there might be one or two African
vagrant larvae around that has been
feeding on it but I can't see any
unfortunately because they're very very
cool so they've got multiple defenses
they're there their body is green and
black so it blends in very well they
this skin is like sandpaper and when
when you touch them they have a very
cool jump reflex so it moves quickly and
and very jerky that might give a bird or
Warner that's trying to feed off them a
fright and enable them to then just keep
still afterwards and escape detection
okay while we're hoping that the lions
and leopards don't evade our detection
well it looks like our katydid friend
has decided still not to jump into the
bus so we'll see how long she lasts in
the meantime let's go send you across to
Steve who's on foot good morning
everyone I hope you're doing very very
well this morning
now welcome to a bushwalk Safari with
myself Steve Falconbridge joined on
camera by Fergus and we obviously joined
once again by herby who's assisting us
with the tracking and the safety on this
magnificent cool morning in Douma in
South Africa we are on a mission sort of
in a south westerly direction at the
moment looking for who knows what we are
too excited please feel free to send
through your comments and questions to
hashtag Safari Live or follow us on the
YouTube stream and let us know what
you'd like to see it is a very nice cool
morning so bring all your equipment with
don't forget your binoculars like I seem
to have done this morning I suddenly
felt very naked on my chest what can you
do what can you do I find mornings like
this really to be cool or not that good
for birding but you never know maybe on
our way back the birds might pick up
t we find a lot of animals through
tracking but then we also find a lot of
them just bumping into them it depends
what we're looking for we don't
generally track elephant and Impala and
kudu the sort of animals we just sort of
come across but we go out in search of
leopard and lion and when we find their
tracks we put in a lot of effort to try
and find them and by understanding the
road network in the direction and where
the water is and the game paths people
like Kirby and Tristan and Brent's
who've been here for long time have a
very good understanding of how these
animals move so if you find for example
we're just crossing another road now if
you find some tracks along the road you
kind of get an idea of a potential game
path for what might be in that direction
when they're moving in a certain
direction then you could just drive
around and if they don't come out the
other side it's a very good chance that
they're inside that block so when it
comes to tracking that is what we do but
in conditions like this after rainfall
as Justin has said 90% of the tracks are
washed away so there is a thunderstorm
last night at about I think 12 1 o'clock
in the morning and it just buckets are
down and there's not a single track to
be seen anyway because what we know when
the rain comes down like this is that
there's water all over the place there's
water on the leaves so the animals don't
have to go very far they can just kind
of drink it off the leaves and stay
where they are without having to mission
all the way to a water point where it's
potentially dangerous Robert I would
love to show you some elephants as well
we saw one yesterday I have no idea
where they've gone this is my first
season working here in Juma so maybe two
individuals like Tristan or Brent might
know where the elephants have moved to
it's possible they've moved to the east
to the basalt Plains there where the
rainfall causes the grasses there and
the knob ponds there to be beautiful so
that's my theory
they've gone that way but let's go over
to either one of those two and see if
they know where the elephants have gone
I don't Steve I've been wondering the
same thing but you might find you're
right that they've headed up towards the
basalt Plains if there's been some good
rain up in those areas then you will
find the alias will go that direction
and they they like that kind of grass
that comes out of there and the
nutrients they can get from that area so
you'll find that they do do that and
also the battle plains areas have most
of it didn't get much rain in the early
summer and they've got a lot of rain
recently so that's maybe why the ILI's
have moved in that direction well so the
way that hasn't really been good weather
you needs Sun and sort of dryness and
then you get a situation where Ellie's
come out and they move towards the water
points because there's not much water
kind of between them whereas now after a
bit of rain they find water in little
mud wallows in the bush and lots of
thickets that they can go into and try
and hide out from the wind and the cold
and the rain and so Ellie's are not
always almost seen animal when we have
conditions like this so we'll just have
to see where they go but I know like I
said it was a big herd around a sidney's
dam not yesterday the day before so
hopefully they'll come our side and
we'll be able to find them and see
something this has been a early draft of
late I've seen very few eighties that's
all right no sign of any of our lions
coming this way no sign of any leopards
so far not that we can see very many
tracks at the moment I'm kind of having
to sort of scan with eyes squinted to
try and see any footprints on the roads
it just kind of has most of it has just
been arraigned on unfortunately so we'll
need to find tracks that are on top of
the rain then we'll be in the running
seat
so leopard girl the biggest animal I've
seen taken down by a leopard mmm I've
seen fully grown could be bull taking
down my leopard which is a massive
individual a rather large giraffe I'm
not a fully grown one but a not a tiny
baby either
I was actually ting gana that took that
down fully grown of all the beasts or so
big instead because they've also seen
them take down a baby elephant but the
baby elephant when it was a brand new
born baby I mean it's not the same size
as something like a fully grown couldi
bull but the danger element in that is
that much more given that the female was
there she was not impressed at all and
was lots of trumpeting and chasing of
elephants and she smashed a whole tree
that an elephant went into so it depends
on one kind of danger versus size but
sighs I would say probably a fully grown
kudu bull or that giraffe those are both
massive massive animals and they managed
to bring them down so it was pretty
weird looking at single on the giraffe
Gilly kind of was dwarfed by this thing
in he didn't they didn't actually
managed to keep it he was mating with
Moya at the time and the two of them
fiddleford for the day and then into the
night and then my eanes came and there
was just no way they were going to keep
it from heiner's unfortunately it's just
too big a carcass for that but it was a
bit of a surreal experience seeing a
female and a male leopard sitting on a
giraffe carcass it was a bit weird it
was not something you're going to see
every single day one because it was two
of them and two because of this prey
animal that they had brought down so you
know lipids are very versatile I'm sure
these reported cases of them even
bringing down in fact actually there was
a situation we we can't say for sure but
we had ting HANA once during a night
Drive following around a rather old
buffalo bull and the buffalo bull was
during the drought wasn't very kind of
steady on his feet and it was a little
bit sort of struggling in terms of the
way
that it was walking and it was you could
see quite weakened and it's time was
coming and then we had a situation where
eating on a arrived and we lift him that
night just kind of literally sitting
right behind the buffalo bull just
following it as it was going and the
next morning we came there and ting gana
was feeding off this dead Buffalo and so
I don't know if he managed to get it by
the throats and actually the Buffalo was
just so we could collapse and he was
able to kind of kill it or if it just
died on its own sort of under its own
sort of conditions and and then ting on
and just scavenged difficult to say but
there was definite bite marks around the
nose and the throat area so maybe he
tried to kill it I don't know it would
be quite a serious feat for a liquid to
bring down a buffalo bull but that's
also in extreme circumstances it's not
because you know it was it's not because
of an easy situation it was just because
of the droughts and and those kind of
things but interesting nonetheless
lipids are amazing animals they it's
pretty crazy that they can do those kind
of things and in in the same sort of
break they'll go in attack what will eat
little things like termites and insects
and and small birds pretty strange that
they can kind of go through all of those
different things that just gives you an
idea of how well they're able to survive
there's a few sightings it's been a long
time in the sabi sands and so been
fortunate to have seen some crazy stuff
with lipids they tend to always come out
with something that will surprise you
you kind of think that they you know are
not capable of suits and things and then
the sudden anyway I'm sure somebody else
who's got Minear Leopard story is brain
Cleo Smith so let's go find out what's
the biggest animal he's seen them kill
me well yes I've been lucky enough to
see some pretty crazy stuff
in my years out in the bush in terms of
leopards baby giraffe is a big one adult
male kudu was a male leopard in Botswana
and took on an adult male could you that
is massive for a leopard
trying to think I've seen leopard
scavenge on elephant carcasses hippo
carcasses but I think the biggest thing
I know Aleph it is caught is an adult
male could you which is incredible
incredibly massive the male effort is
caught the biggest things in this part
of the world since I've been yet it's
definitely quarantine
it's called quite a few sub adult male
could do to the two three year old male
kudu which are a very big I female kudu
so yes so there is a there is a
precedence that certain males seem to
definitely focus on bigger prey than
others and also those males that focus
on bigger prey also seems to be far less
tolerant of hyenas and yes Jamie I think
Jamie's seen it twice in the Mara male
leopard with giraffe up the tree k6 was
remembering that so that I think he was
called the Shepherds tree mail he seemed
to like giraffe I also know there's some
male leopards are on the Sand River that
have been recorded taking giraffes
actually I suppose doesn't really very
big pay for a leopard was a an adult
zebra in the Mara but it had already
been injured by crocodiles and had a
broken leg and then the leopard and the
crocodile fed from either side I didn't
see it so it was the year before we
arrived
and so I suppose but as ever was still
alive and it got out of the water and in
the leopard was suffocating it and the
crocodile came and grabbed it from the
other side I saw photographs of that
from Boyd Chris Boyd I think from from
from solace they were lucky enough to
see that mark boy Thank You Nicholas
Mark Boyd from Sylas he he saw that in
enjoying the migration
so crazy stuff does happen and sometimes
you're lucky enough to be there I still
think the craziest in terms of hunts
that I've ever seen is lion and elephant
and lion and rhino as the boys always
been the the moat and line and hippo for
that matter but that's more common but
lion runner and lion and elephant are
really really crazy to watch in you
you've often got to be very careful in
those situations where where you park
because a stressed elephant just
charging around with 2530 lions trying
to jump on it now there's elephants are
big 15 to 20 years old and there's
certain prides of lions and in Botswana
that target those young males that have
left have been pushed out of the herds
and are pretty solitary I haven't seen
without late rains we're starting to see
some spiders and stuff that we don't we
haven't seen too much of this yet yet
those who are arachnophobia golden orb
spider female now you can see there's a
lot of carcasses in the middle of her
web and she leaves the carapace --is and
exoskeletons of the the insect she eats
in her web so birds don't fly through it
now
this isn't it's a big spider but they
can get double triple the size of that
and they've even been recorded catching
small birds like wax bulls and fire
finches I'm just trying to see I can't
if we look around to the edges of the
web okay so like maybe a little bit down
I think I can see I'm trying to see if
we can spot a male so males tend to hide
on the peripheries they've well done
Craig well no that's a fly that's been
caught but we're trying to see said the
males there's a male
who's that a dewdrop that's a dewdrop
spider that's a klepto parasite so those
little spiders live on the webs and they
eat the little pieces that are too small
for the the bigger spider to eat the
male's however will be on oh she's
picked up on the something's in her web
something fresh see how she's using her
feet to test where the vibrations are
coming from she's decided oh you've it's
quite small the thing that flew into the
web says she's fault Dez oh she's got a
fly it's breakfast
isn't that cool we got some hyenas
pooping
back down towards the Marathi now all
spiders all choose spiders are venomous
if they're not poisonous
poison is ingested venom is injected but
all spite all true spiders are venomous
however the spider has got a saw bite
but it's not a danger to human beings at
all look how she's how she's busy
spinning web around it and she might be
quite full so she might be saving that
fly for later okay leave her to stock up
on her ladder and it sounds like Tristan
hasn't got his favourite animal but he's
got his favorite animals favourite food
I do but I've got a very interesting one
that we see from time to time in this
area it's the one that's busy going to
the toilet which is helpful so you try
and discern it from the others
unfortunately it's facing away from us
so seeing what makes it unique is quite
different difficult but this is an
Impala that we've seen from time to time
that has a horn growing out from its
nose area basically between its eyes and
its nostrils on its face there is a
little horn it grows out it's a very
underdeveloped one given that she's a
female it's not surprising that she's
got this undeveloped horn now hopefully
when she's finished going to the toilet
she'll turn her face but there you can
just make it art between the eyes and
the nose you see there's a sort of ridge
there there it is you see it there
coming out of the face so very very
unusual to see something like that and
it's it does happen in females sometimes
they will have a little bit of a defect
and they grow horns the ones are pretty
underdeveloped but to grow it in that
area is very very strange so there you
can just see it kind of on the nose or
the bridge of her nose should we call it
and that kind of porn is growing a
little bit since the last time I saw it
it was much straighter it's now kind of
curled back down towards her face and is
kind of growing in walk back towards her
which is gonna be interesting to see how
she copes with that but amazing isn't it
it's not something you're gonna see
every single day like I say a very
developed one so it's a little piece of
bone that's growing out a little bit of
carotene over the top in fact it's
probably fine that there's not even much
bone in there doll it's mostly carotene
that's coming out which is pretty weird
mrs. grumpy is that you love this little
unicorn it's very cool isn't it and like
I say we've seen this I don't know I've
seen it twice I think showing you guys
that twice before and I think Taylor
might have seen it before
biron one of the two of them so it is a
Impala that does hang around normally be
anywhere between sort of Gallagher and
where I am now
just north of in pilot planes it kind of
moves in this way stand sector and it
just goes to show that some of our
Impala herds are regulated in this area
even though we can't really do this
whole the difference when you see this
individual it gives you an idea that
some of the impalas spend a lot of time
and hey if you didn't know that there
was one that had this and you looked at
them from here you would never ever ever
be able to spot that it's got a kind of
little horn growing out of its face it's
it's something that's only if you've not
seen it and you'd kind of look at the
females can you pick it up quite quickly
but I'm just going to reverse back so we
can follow her so should have a better
view of her now she's the first one in
that whole row there we go so now you
can actually see it quite nicely just
that sort of little horn sticking out
amazing isn't it such an anomaly so
pearl you say April 9th is unicorn day
is that for real because if this really
is a unicorn day and we found this in
partner that will be pretty weird and
quite fun but it's amazing to me ad
especially it crows from like I say I've
seen females with horns generally it
comes from the top between the ears like
where the male's have it very seldom do
you see them coming out of the face like
this it's pretty weird but interesting
Mandie at the moment no you can see
she's a healthy individual she's walking
around just like everybody else and it's
not obscuring her vision or hearing or
anything like that so it doesn't seem to
affect her in any way it's also not
gonna cause any infections or anything
untoward the size of it also won't weigh
her down it's not gonna get caught up in
branches too much so she seems to be
fine I think the only thing is if it
grows and continues to curl towards her
face she might have a situation me it's
going to cause a bit of damage to her
face somewhere or something like that
but for now it seems as though it's
absolutely fine Jeff I don't think so
I'm pretty sure males of the impala kind
are not picky particularly because most
of the time that they are mating with
females is because they smell like
they've come into Easter's it's not so
much of physical appearance with them
it's not the other way around
females were from judge males on a
physical appearance of the horns and
they size was a male just kind of gets
driven by the scent that he's picking up
if the females in estrus and he picks up
that she's ready to mate that drive is
there and he's so hot up because of the
rut and all those kind of things then
I'm pretty sure he will mate with a
female like that it's gonna be
interesting I mean hopefully she's
around come November December January
February and we hopefully see her with a
little one cuz then we would know if she
has a little bit more she did get mated
with to be able to say otherwise
so really his national international
unicorn day today can you believe it
that's absolutely ridiculous you found
this in father on unicorn day that's
what is the chances it's ridiculously
sort of coincidence but anyway good
happy international unicorn day
everybody I don't know what happened but
anyway how these things happen I don't
know anyway let's go back to Steve let's
go see what he's up to where he's
walking you know what his plans are for
the morning thanks Justin did you all
know out there that the unicorn is in
fact the national animal of Scotland
true story
fine is that mud sand so we were talking
about elephant movements
and I think for ease of understanding I
have got out my fantastic tree book
let's have a look at where we are
understand the loaf a little bit more
and then show you a cross-section of the
Kruger Park to see exactly where the
soil is and why the elephants might have
moved so first of all we're going to go
into South Africa here we have South
Africa Cape Town is down here in the far
southwest but we are all the way up here
inland Popa and Mpumalanga province
where you see the green is essentially
what this book relates to and we are
over there okay so now I'm gonna go and
show you a quick picture of the Kruger
Park itself
let me just turn the page here is the
Kruger Park in its entirety with much
more included the Kruger Park is this
boundary line here all the way and
there's Mozambique and fence line
although out there and we are over here
somewhere sabi sands is this section
over there and the Tim of our te and
class area all forming up on the side
here so this is all private game
reserves and you can see how it all
falls within a particular color and this
is granite the the pinkish sort of
oranges granite this gray is basalt we
talked about the bessel before and then
the pink all the way along the eastern
side is the lebombo mountains and this
legend is the low felt the Drakensberg
runs along and the entire eastern side
here the bombo's along the sorry the
darkest Berg's on the western side the
lebombo mountains on the eastern side
everything in between is what we call
the low felts so if i quickly jump back
to a cross-section of the low felt you
can see this is west over here all the
way across to east over here and you can
see the different soil types you see are
granite takes up a huge portion there's
a small section of sand felt and then
basalt and then rhyolite now to
understand this better the granite is
very very old rock we took about 2.8
billion years and the granite was magma
that never came to the surface and as
everything above it eroded away if
there's what's revealed the granite we
don't
see too much granite actual visible in
this area but they are very very obvious
with these rocky outcrops which are
quite obvious in some areas elsewhere in
the sabi sands and around but the soil
is very very hot oh it's very very
porous not very not a huge amount of
nutrients and the water that lands here
goes straight through so any nutrients
that are they move down so you get very
particular type of soil and particular
type of plants types in these areas and
this is where we are but if you go all
the way to the east the bath salts there
that is lava that was deposited on the
Earth's surface
probably 118 million years ago 130 280
million years and a very soft rock but
very high in nutrients lots and lots of
volcanic material and nutrients and the
soil that is very clay like holds the
water very very well and it gives rise
to very sweet grasses and trees so when
there's rainfall in the summer months
all of the migrating animals including
elephant will move into this area where
the food is very nice and tasty so I
hope that answers some of the questions
and you get a bit of an idea of where we
are and the diversity of the low felt is
because of those different soil types
and just to jump back to the Kruger Park
what also adds to the diversity not just
the soil type but the rainfall gradient
is lower up here and increases as you go
south so as you go south towards sort of
Pretoria Scorpio Cuza
the rainfall is the highest that you get
in the park and so you get even more
leaching of the soil so the granitic
soils are even lower in nutrients then
further north so that's where you get so
many different vegetation units within
this complex of only three or four soil
types
that's it what would I eat if our
strainer there is lots of things to eat
let me quickly grab you some off the top
of my mind I can see there is some magic
worry seeds here very very delicious let
me grab a couple there's a quarry look
at those those are quite tasty hmm so
that's number one
we're ready munching on the the white
berry bush just before they have fruits
it again and hmm if there must they must
be this color if you grab them where now
this color when you grab them when
they're green do you want to see my face
but she did so better it's very bit done
that's all you know birds can see color
because birds will eat fruit when it's
ripe they know when it's red and Ferg is
gonna have one as well mmm tasty tasty
hmm you can see how big the seed is
inside it's very fresh very nice it's
almost like a plum a little bit more
bitter than the plum but very similar in
consistency and texture okay so I hope
the explanation of the low felts in
where we are explains a little bit more
about what's going on and why we see
what we do and cuz of the soil here
that's why we get quite a similar sort
of vegetation unit and I'm not able to
show you hundreds of trees only that
small selection that we've been through
craft is - joy and Michael what happened
last night off the drive was really
something quite special Craig and I are
followed to the Oklahoma pride we
followed them afraid you saw that last
closing segments we lost sight to them
for a few moments we continued following
them they crossed another road we
decided to stay in the road and wait for
them just as she was going on and then
all the Yanks is just stood very still
very still with is looking in the
direction so Craig and I switched off
the car we listened for some time and
then we heard some running branches
moving and then we heard the
characteristic what well oh I'm not very
good at that of a kudu barking we
listened to listened listened a next
thing we heard the Lions take down the
kudu took us about three four minutes to
get in there because it was quite thick
and we found them uncle homers
absolutely smashing a female could or a
young could do we're not sure I never
got a look at the head wallah nose was a
kudu because I saw two of them walk off
with the leg and there was a tail but
never found any horns or a head so
they're practically ate the ribs
everything they just smashed it so that
was very very special and that probably
happened five to ten minutes after the
close of drop which is very very sad for
all of you out there but Craig and I had
a marvelous afternoon evening the ladies
in FC were super jealous of us and were
constantly commenting on the radio with
things like is this making you hungry
and I was going no not really
not really because you know I'm a
vegetarian watching an animal get eaten
alive doesn't do anything to my to my
tummy sorry just a very quick little
look here at this is granite that is
granite we see them when we look in
these little riverbeds you can see how
crumbly it is at the moment but look how
large those particles are very sandy
very coarse-grained very very coarse
any water that lands on these soils just
sinks through to the bottom okay on that
note let's go over to Brent Leo Smith
and hopefully he's feeling much better
but we tried to find with these lines
now that Steve had Craig was with them
so only there was somewhere in this area
where they got that could you but it
looks like they might have moved off a
little bit so if we don't get any
lacquer on ya we might have to check
don't know if they would have gone as
far as buffle took damn if they had a
good feed they might just be lying happy
and comatosed
somewhere in this area well there's what
they were eating last night so they
asked them could you still in the area
but no sign of the lines just yet
but it sounds like Tristan's got a
feathered friend who will be departing
for warmer climes soon indeed I'm
actually quite surprised that this
individual is still here it's getting
quite late now for Warburg's to still be
hanging around but this is one of our
pale forms that's still here well sir
one that I haven't seen much of on this
western side so I don't know if it's one
of the ones it's kind of finished up
nesting around ton dams or Wahlberg's
area and kind of now slowly but surely
he's going to think about departing but
I'm looking a bit ruffled up there with
the wind you can see the clouds moving
in the background as it's sitting there
and kind of slowly but surely it's going
to seem as though they cards we need to
get blown away which is going to be
quite a nice but this guy we know is the
Wahlberg's it's quite easy to tell
you've got that little crease that's
sticking up that bright yellow seer and
then you can see a long tail that's
sticking out from sort of the tail or
the wing area and then you've got the
birds sitting in a sort of quite upright
manner the reason it's leaning a little
bit forward more than normal is because
of the wind that's blowing so just kind
of counterbalancing unless it's a little
bit more upright but the crest on the
yellow sea upper will be the biggest
identifying features on this bird and
the four say yellow feet makes it much
easier to be
to tell that it's that there are a
couple of other birds that you can
sometimes confuse it with so booted
Eagles and and the likes but these guys
with that like I say what that crest
just gives them away immediately now
it's sitting probably because of the
conditions that we've got this overcast
cloudy where there's not great for
flying or though Wahlberg's typically
are not like vultures or some of the
other eagle species that will ride
thermals these guys are often a lot kind
of lowered to the ground in a sort of
short flying birds you'll find them kind
of going from sort of treetop to treetop
and in their hunt Birds they'll hunts
winged alerts from termites so those
kind of things which doesn't require
huge amounts of flying for long periods
in order to find them so you do find
them perched quite regularly there's
gonna be interesting I wonder if they
stayed a little longer this year just
because of the rain that we had and we
interesting was her to know what which
was that when was the last time we saw
Wahlberg's last year so what does the
last world we've seen on drives asked if
anybody knows hashtags for a live or
YouTube chat let us know when we last
saw a Wahlberg's and if we have passed
that date or are we in a similar time
frame as to last year both last year and
this year we've had late rain which is
old I think some of the migratory birds
like all those Eagles a little longer I
did see a lesser spotted eagle yesterday
I think it was yesterday morning maybe
and so they are around some of the
migratory birds but it must be the last
few that us gonna start heading back
funny enough also haven't seen very many
red back tracks this morning they were
around yesterday morning in the day
before but I haven't seen any today yet
which they were everywhere at one point
and so so much quieter and here they
little fishing sort of chirpy sound that
they sometimes have Archer so I wonder
if maybe just maybe
they've started to leave now as all with
this kind of cold front and pushed in in
the winds that we've got maybe they
decided they are going to start hitting
back north as well so it's so sad in all
of our migratory birds start to leave I
get sad they provide so much color and
sort of variety to our bird life so he's
very nice to have them in this area good
one no one else is in store for us this
morning very quiet from an animal point
of view I don't know unicorn which I
suppose is special nonetheless we should
take that just both hands given that it
is the day that it is get my brain
working because I'm drawing a blank as
to what the longest migratory bird is I
I'm sure Steve will print will know
straightaway I do know the answer to
this but I've honestly at the moment
just trying to think now read this many
many many many many many times but I
just can't think of it right now okay
I'll think about it maybe Steve will we
have the answer so let's go ahead and
send you across to him while I try and
see if I can scramble the information in
my own brain hmm thanks Justin sorry we
just stopped for a little bit of what we
call in South Africa Pat course a little
bit of food for the road mmm white berry
bush
marvelous look I'm sorted for the
morning and very very tasty very very
juicy seeds so this is one of the things
that you would eat in the bush
and we are bumbling around from tree to
tree so the largest migrating bird or
the furthest migrating bird I think Judy
edge sends a little article on Twitter
the other nights thank you for that very
interesting
it is the Arctic Tern which is now going
more than 6,000 miles further than the
[ __ ] Shearwater which is a bird they
thought used to cover the greatest
distance six thousand miles further than
that one they come down from Antarctica
are to go down Africa South America and
back again and it's all about feeding
it's all about the movement of fish in
the water that's in a marvelous distance
the
cliff drops about 30 years and they're
not putting on these very small little
transmitters that way about a gram on
their foots and they're getting all
these zigzagging movements they don't go
in a straight line they kind of move
like this so they go so much further
than they need to but it's all about
energy and they're feeding along as they
go so that is a marvelous article that
we read just the other day and that's
truth because they got the trackers on
the bird now before all we could know
about was we'd see a bird some way and
okay cool as the crow flies they've gone
from here to there but now with the
actual GPS tracker and I know exactly
how far the birds have gone and I think
it's like 17,000 miles or something in a
year flying and imagine that's some
serious a a miles I wonder if there and
they have no passports they have no
customs control they just they just go
isn't it marvelous
no security checks they don't have to
take off their shoes or their belt the
good old days the good old days okay
yeah I am a bit of both gem video
browser an aggressor it just depends on
what leaf type so here is a very nice
grass this is known as red grass and
this is grass tit to be associated with
basaltic soils we go up to the Maasai
Mara the red oak grass everybody talks
about it there it's the same species
this is out of ten you would say ten out
of ten and this grows very very well on
nutrient-rich soils here in the sabi
sands we find it in small sporadic
places it's got nothing to do with an
overall layout but in the Mara this is
the dominant grass species that brings
in the millions of animals that come
there to graze so this is a very nice
species and when we find lots of it you
could call it very good grazing but here
we find it just in a little patch little
patch here as we keep moving it's going
to disappear again so a very nice grass
to to munch on and to graze
regu this stick is a stick I found up in
the northern Kruger a friend of mine
actually found it and he gave it an oil
and then he left it on the deck of the
room are staying in he went on leave
I needed a stick to go walking I'd left
mastic I'd been in an elephant encounter
one afternoon where I'd left my stick on
the ground purely because we had to to
leave the scene very quickly we were
sitting down elephants came in and we
quickly retreated up onto the rocks and
I left my stick and so the next day I
needed one and I found this and it's
marvelous it is my wisdom stick it's got
lots of stories to tell it's nice and
polished now from my hand and it's
lovely to walk with the stick you can
evade spider webs
you can point things out you can hit
fergus on the head when he's not paying
attention very important very important
to have a stick out here pointing out
tracks also when you start getting old
like me and you want to point our tracks
on the floor it's much easier to point
with your stick they'd so physically get
quite old well talking about getting old
and people with injuries let's go over
to see how brent is doing ha hi Steve ha
ha you're older than me
so since Steve's come back and Fergus
have come back the old men have come
back so I'm known for a while I think
Sebastian and I were the two oldest in
camp but we are not anymore we've handed
over that to Steven fig
so we had tracks of the the lines coming
out of that thick block they lay on the
road here for a bit so I'm just going to
check round on the next road otherwise
they're sleeping somewhere between here
and bottles are damn
if they haven't gone north or west or
east or but it doesn't look like us
last night on the Sun sunset Safari we
saw a very old male lion from the
Magellan coalition so there used to be
four there's only two left and
apparently both of them are in that
really really bad States like we saw
that that male yesterday
so far no updates on him this morning he
crushed him to Aerith lose the last
night we haven't heard anything yet this
morning but he is about 14 years old
which is incredibly old for a firm
airline so currently in the western
sections of the sabi sands there are no
dominant male lions there's apparently
one two and a half year old auto ally
and he thinks he's the bee's knees
however we just heard that the
Birmingham's are mating on Londos and I
think what's going to happen is they're
gonna push west into that area that is
devoid of male lions which is troubling
news for the in Goma Torchwood and Styx
prides less so for the Styx then the
other two but these northern prides are
probably at great risk at the moment so
they're very great risk at the moment is
there the Torchwood's and the in corners
as the Birmingham's are looking to
probably spend more time down south and
maybe even head west from there as we
were just saying there to Magellan males
still alive and both in very bad
condition like the one we saw yesterday
both sort of eating out in existence
often that when male lions get to that
sort of state they eat tortoises and
Terrapins and and anything now even if
they had to come across in calmer pride
or or anything like that that those
lionesses would probably kill a male and
like that especially if it's not one of
the males from there they're there their
coalition so it's going to be very
interesting what happens with the Lions
and the Leopards at the moment there is
so much upheaval in the dynamics
just checking carefully I think these
are the tracks from when Steve was
following last night now one of the
biggest myths that is perpetrated out on
Safari is that bright colors will cause
animals to charge and react and
everything
Sao Paulo most animals see in a various
monotone colors especially the Predators
and the only things that really see in
true color are cats not cats Oh monkeys
as cats don't really see in true color
so lions sort of see in a monotone
greeny gray probably very similar to
what we see in IR except without the
definition that we see so strangely
enough that the two colors that stick up
the most in the African bush are black
and white because they are really really
prominent solid blocks of color
so that whole neutral colors and whatnot
that you get told to wear and Safari is
more so as not to offend the other
people on the vehicle then to offend the
animals as most animals couldn't care if
you're wearing neon pink
okay now have these lines arrived at
Buffalo K it's a possibility that you
like this area oh yeah so while we keep
meandering towards the Buffalo Gorge all
it seems like Steve has found something
else on bushwalk yes I have once again
looking at a very nice tree one of the
favorite trees Archer not only from a
food point of view but from a spiritual
and cultural point of view the buffalo
thorn very easy to see by the straight
hook and the backward hook and this is
one of the favorite browsing plants for
myself
it's a substitute for spinach and very
very tasty when the fruits are up you
can actually eat them as well they are
red berry dark fruit with a very hard
seed inside and you must eat them when
they're red and they're very very tasty
but what I was going to talk about is
how this buffalo thorn is growing has
actually facilitated enormous amount of
of growth of two types of grasses the
first one we have seen already is the
red the great grass the red oak grass or
for me to try Andhra and the second one
is this wonderful panikker maximum blue
Guinea grass there's a lot of common
names out there and talked about grazing
and browsing here I'm eating the leaves
and here I'm eating the seeds seeds are
very tasty and the base of these grass
stalks are so juicy hmm you can eat them
all day as we walk through we're
constantly pulling these up and eating
them and these are one of the grasses
that need semi-shade it's a reason why
they don't grow really much up in the
Mara cause is not much shade they need a
semi shade and semi Sun and they grow
very very well in the undergrowth like
this protected by trees like the Buffalo
thought very very marvelous but the
reason why I actually wanted you to come
back to me was we found a rock and this
rock is very easily identified by the
very large sort of granules in there and
that sort of dark orangey color to it
now this rock is known as ferric
and it is the youngest rocks you find on
earth at the moment and a very good
geologist friend of mine told me that
these rocks actually when historians
look back or a new civilization looks
back on the human world they can
actually correlate this rock with the
existence of homo sapien how interesting
is that so we're looking at about two
million years which is very young in the
scope of a rock but these rocks are
being formed as we speak there are
sedimentary rocks which means they are
deposited soil particles moving and then
getting compacted through lithification
and these rocks are correlated with the
existence of the human species I think
that is an absolutely marvelous story
when you think about the granite 2.8
billion years that is enormous amount of
time and even the best thoughts 150 250
million it's a very long time verses
about one to two million years marvelous
indeed are you going to leave this right
here we found it and we'll continue on
joy and ale if we find invasive plant
species we will definitely remove them I
don't haven't found too many while I've
been walking around but a lot of the
invasive species come in as I've said a
few times before via the extensive river
systems that come in from the West I
showed you that photo of the map that
entire map runs from north to south and
all the rivers come in from the West so
those perennial rivers those
free-flowing rivers that flow all year
round are the bringers of agricultural
pests and problem plants and we don't
find many of them here in doom itself
because we don't have a perennial River
system moving through but if we do find
will show you and we'll pull them out so
we are walking as you can see let's go
with Justin Dix who is driving
indeed we are we are driving with very
little success at this rate so we've
come to tryouts damn now which means
we'll just have a little stop here and
have a little look around as to what's
going on and see if there's anything
that's looking is that oh no it's just a
lot for a second yeah I thought maybe
there was a crocodile that was
interesting but it's not it's just a log
that is positioned kind of oh is it mud
might be mud
yes it's mud that's what it is so I
thought for a second day it was a croc
that was that was sitting kind of on the
edge of the woods as briefly glanced at
it but it's definitely mad now shales
dam is quiet there is literally we have
not seen a single track from after the
rain so there's been nothing moving
around maybe everybody's decided it's
bad weather and it's decided to have a
bit of a nap so I'm not sure actually
where I'm going to hit from here I might
head to the elephant carcass just again
see we haven't been there for a few days
you never know maybe something lurking
around that side so we're going to have
a little chick around they and hopefully
windy behaves herself in that area now
I'm glad that we resolved the longest
migratory bird I was funny as we kind of
st. you to Steve I said to since I'm 99%
sure it's the turn and then I wasn't you
know I was just drawing a blank and I
mean you know it was confirmed Arctic
Tern and you know all the information
comes back which is good but anyway
that's the way it goes sometimes you
forget things now Julie largest
migratory birds hmm I'm actually not
even sure about this you know what would
we say what would we say largest would
be--would largest be heaviest or largest
would be biggest wingspan or would it be
there's different parameters and is
heaviest and is sort of longest wingspan
I would say probably I might be wrong in
this but maybe one of the stork species
would be one of the large birds
misbehaving is also a violation should
Fernanda his comedic
terribly sorry about there ladies and
gentlemen having a few technical issues
with windy but don't you worry we are
back with bushwalk and we have found a
magnificent specimen of a golden orb web
spider this is the female she is about
200 times bigger and then the male and
look at those beautiful colors the black
the orange a very contrasting it stands
out quite brightly and that is to
indicate two birds potentially its
toxicity if eaten I don't know if it is
poisonous to eat what I do know is that
it is slightly venomous if it did give
you a bite it would only give you a mild
headache so nothing to be worried about
it's not one of the dangerous or human
fearing spiders out there but the name
golden orb comes from the beautiful
golden web that it spins and this female
actually has got an ecosystem or should
we say a party to herself
first of all in her web which you can
see now at that beautiful golden light
there is her junk line in the middle
there that is where the remains of her
of her kills she puts the make as it
stands out quite easily from a distance
you can clearly see that line it
hopefully deters an animal from walking
through and then over here you can see
there is a male there is a male here
there's two males in fact in the sweat
and what I always marvel at is quite
often the males are missing a leg or two
the one male is got all of his legs
albeit one of them is half and the other
male is missing a few legs and that is
because whenever they try to mate with
the female they're living in her web
this guy's missing most of his legs he's
only got five legs he should have eight
so what happens in fact is they're live
in the web and they want to mate with
the female so when they touch the web
the female gets excited about food she
goes rushing off there to go catch the
food and then the male will often drop
down a line and sort of escape and then
come back again and he learns to play a
very particular tune on the web a little
sort of serenade for the
female you could say and then eventually
she realizes oh hang on maybe this is a
mating partner and then she does not eat
him but it's very common to find them
missing legs so they live in the web
with the female and she does most of the
hunting and catching that's right we
learned to play the guitar to serenade
the ladies hmm Paula I have no idea what
the average weight is but these spiders
have been known to catch small birds in
these webs they are very very strong so
small Finch like bird of about maybe 9
to 10 grams could potentially get caught
in these webs but the thing is as the
spider won't be able to eat them and it
just damages the web hence the fact that
they put these drag lines or often a
Stabila mentum to show other organisms
that the web is here and to try steer
clear but what is very interesting is
we've got a parasitic spider within the
web if Eric's gonna try to focus on it
and there's quite a few of them there
they known as a dewdrop spider and I
wonder if you look at it looks like a
little drop of mercury and they live in
the web of the golden orb spider and
they are actually klepto parasites which
means that they steal to know what a
kleptomaniac is is someone who steals so
klepto parasite is there live in the web
of the female golden orb and they all
feed on catch that she has wrapped up
ready for digestion so they don't seem
to affect her too much because they're
so small and she doesn't seem to hunt
them down but they will steal bits and
pieces of a food just like a tick
stealing the blood out of an animal they
will not kill the spider but they are
stealing its food so klepto parasite a
very interesting symbiotic relationship
and I wonder if you can actually see
that mercury lack ball on their bum
Cece and Mysterio we're going to show
you how big the spider is I'm gonna come
stand on the other side of it and then
folks gonna get a bit of a relation in
that you can see how big it is compared
to my fingers here that's about half the
length of my index finger if you can see
that I'm not afraid of her because she's
not going to try bite me
there she is beautiful Hey absolutely
beautiful and what will happen is after
mating and after laying eggs in the tree
itself and she's about as big as so they
can get a little bit bigger than that
what is she doing is she laying me why
she's sticking some more web it's
possible that her we've got a little bit
damaged last night she's gonna remake
some of it and after laying eggs in the
tree soon she will die and the next
season they will hatch again and the
whole process of the golden orbs ecology
begins again rev Indus the revenant
Paula spiders have got a very special
mechanism on their feet which enables
them to walk over their web without
getting stuck it is obviously unique to
spiders they don't get stuck in the web
I don't know exactly how it works but
the web is designed by them and
facilitated by them and so if they got
stuck in it evolution just would not
continue
so they've evolved obviously to live in
a web to produce the web to gobble it up
as well or to to spin it whenever they
need and so they are very adept at not
getting stuck I saw some little eggs
over here fair girls on the other side I
saw some little white patches okay well
it looks like Justin has managed to get
back into a better signal area so let's
leave our spider and go over to him some
bait the signal I want to just head
quickly towards Janet Jackson's home and
see if maybe she's home on a cold day
like today
whichever one it is and see whether or
not they are relaxing in the little hole
and appearing outs now we were
discussing largest migratory birds and I
wasn't a hundred percent sure what they
were but I went and checked it out
quickly just to kind of make sure and
see what it was and interestingly enough
it is a pelican so the great white
pelican is the largest migratory bird
apparently in the world which is pretty
interesting it has a wingspan of over
two meters and is the largest one
according to some articles now I don't
know if that's just applies to the
Americas or if it applies to us as well
but I mean here in southern Africa
obviously we don't see much of a
migration of pelicans at all and we
don't see much of a migration in terms
of any of the other top ten birds that
they are in that list so I'll tell you
what the top ten birds are met according
to a certain list that I found which
would be let me just get it for us
quickly so in number 10 is the Canadian
goose that is apparently a bird that is
got 1.7 2 meter wingspan and these geese
follow over North America basically and
they are the most distributed use in
North America then you've got the great
blue here and I have a funny feeling
this is an American migratory list but
anyway let's just have a look then
you've got the great blue heron then
you've got a turkey vulture golden eagle
bald eagle sandhill crane Tundra Swan
whooping crane trumpet this one and then
american white pelican it's pretty much
all the North American species I don't
know if this is completely true but it
does say this is the world's sort of
migratory birds but I think it must be
the American Maya tree bird so maybe
somebody can help us and see what the
world's is be interesting to see I my
first thought would have been one of the
sort of like I say cranes maybe storks
for us here in southern Africa but in
terms of the world I'm a die-hard
potential now
no Jenna Jackson today as well that's
its so let's carry on and see I'm
interested to know though if somebody
can find what our largest South African
migratory bird is maybe I'm just curious
to know what it is
do you all know I haven't checked the
barn owl nest recently just from a
simple fact that I haven't actually been
on Chitra recently I spent a very little
time in the time that I was there the
other day we had kochava and the little
one and in ting ganas I doesn't actually
get a chance to get this I might get
there today
now sins on the road over here is a
crime scene of some sort maybe a bit
closed right yeah so the pole might be
all the car might be in the way but
there's the shell of a tortoise who I
need to move a little bit
sorry sins let me go back a little bit
sorry I thought I had enough space but
evidently not
here we go since that should be better
so is interesting to see because this is
just the sort of bottom side of a
tortoise but I don't see any other signs
of it and that's very strange normally
when you have a situation where tortoise
is cleaned up in eaten then you'll find
bits of it broken all over the place of
its old image you see them kind of
separated in half like this and stole
some of the flesh there but no signs of
the rest of the shell so now wonder if
this was maybe killed somewhere else and
then something like a young hyena picked
it up and carried it around or what the
actual situation is a Constantine I
straps around it so I think this has
been here for a day or two and then the
rain has washed over whatever had walked
here hmm interesting that's for sure
tortoises they're getting absolutely
hammered at the moment this is about the
third dead tortoise I've seen in the
last couple days okay well we're going
to leave our tortoise we need to head
down towards the elephant carcass I see
there's a few fresh tracks for hyenas
going in that direction so maybe we'll
get some painting action at the carcass
itself I know a lot of you love behind
and so I'll try and see if we can find
that houses here a great go away bird
calling quite a bit just see this guy's
slowly I just wanna check sometimes they
can be a good indicator that something's
lurking no sir quiet now okay we'll
carry on down towards the elephant
carcass while we do have to send you to
print who I think has found what Steve
saw last night well we have we've
arrived at the remnants of the kudu and
I think it's quite a young could you
just judging by how little of its left
and on the jawbone it's not a big big
jawbone at all even though part of its
chewed off I think it's quite a young
young kudu sub-adult and the fact that
there's all the ribcage most of the
vertebrae gone is only a jawbone and two
scapulars left chair I'm hoping that the
Lions aren't too far away now quite
interesting me even if we didn't know it
was a coup D we could surmise it was a
kudu even if we didn't have the jawbone
to look at because if you look at some
of the undigested stomach contents you
can see all the leaves and it looks like
these could have been eating quite a lot
of round-leaf teak so you can see hasn't
been ruminated fully yet and there's
quite a lot of leaves inside it now
the other reason I know it's a small
canoe is just from the size of the
stomach contents a big hoodie would be a
lot more stomach now the Lions seem to
have come out to come back in here and I
think we heard of Franklin alarming not
too far away I'm hoping they're lying up
just they're all they're just about to
get moving so we're gonna try to
negotiate our way through this thick
area
to see if we can catch up with the Lions
now since it is national unicorn dad
I've got a question for you to ponder
before I send you back to Steve and that
why did Scotland choose the unicorn as
their national emblem or national animal
okay
think about that hashtag safari live in
the meantime Steve's doing some
flowering yes we are Thank You Brent and
Baathists are able to find that kudu
carcass and I'm happy to see that my
assumption said it was a small crew or
young kudu are correct and then as
purely because we watched those Lions
just devour the bones as if there were
nothing so the reason our stock share is
we found two beautiful flowers which are
related both of them this is the blue
wandering jew orca Melina and here is
the yellow and then the common name for
them as Mickey Mouse ears which you can
quite easily see in the shape of them
and these are very well known for if you
use the leaves themselves you make them
into a drink are very good to cure any
bladder problems that you might have and
I've also heard the story that you can
actually there's a little droplet that
gets caught in over there and you can
use that as an eye wash as eyedrops if
need be and a marvelous to see both of
them together why one is yellow and one
is is blue no idea but I mean you can
see the flowering parts and the shape of
them are identical but it's just the
color so the color itself will actually
attract a different type of insect so
yellows you're expected to attract sort
of daytime animals and blues and purples
are sort of more for the nocturnal
spectrum but all flowers have got a UV
signature and we know all insects
actually follow UV signatures versus
color so to speak because they see in a
very different level to what we see
but marvelous another situation or
another thing I wanted to talk about was
we're talking about grazing and browsing
again this morning I found another
beautiful flower not flower but grass
this is very easy to identify Nikki I
tortured this one yesterday it looks
like some fingers this is the finger
grass and very very tasty out of the two
other grasses that showed you the red
grass and the the blue buffalo grass or
white buffalo grass I keep getting their
common name mixed up panic a maximum
this is on the par with it with regards
to feeding and you can tell that by hmmm
very very juicy
but now ladies and gentlemen how can I
be aggressor it's not possible if I had
to take this grass here and eat it it
would caused me to vomit I just would we
are not designed to eat grass the food
that we eat we are they need to eat
completely raw or we need to cook it and
grasses if you ever see a cat or a dog
they eat grass and it's offered to cough
up a fur ball saw one of the lionesses
last night eat some of the grass and she
coughed up a fur ball with some bones in
it it's quite revolting but it is a an
emetic which causes you to to
regurgitate whatever it is you have in
your tummy so we are not able to digest
grass we probably were at one stage but
our pendeks has altogether disappeared
and in one stage it is probably quite
similar to that of a grazing animal very
large cecum for digesting those sort of
things so we can't directly grass i have
tried before it does not work it's
curved Tristan who has managed to find a
dead elephant caucus well not very
difficult to find it's it's been here
for the last three weeks
fairly easy to go and don't really know
anyway you know very much left of this
elephant is amazing how a few weeks ago
this was a full elephant and it was
alive and now look at what it's been
reduced to you can see you have a hyena
that's also in the area it's just
chomping down on bones and it is
literally all that is left there's a bit
of skin here and there that they've
eaten after the rain
skin is softened up and looks like a
blanket that has been dragged all over
the place but it's actually the skin
that is around so there it is
say Kira who's 11 years old was asking
have I ever seen I know Kira we have
seen I what we see is regularly almost
most days in fact maybe we don't get
them on the show every single day but as
we live in and work in this area so we
get them pretty much every day we hear
them every night they very common Archer
and there's lots of them and they love
these kind of things where they can find
a carcass like this and it's amazing to
watch them go to town and to try and
feed off all of this kind of thing the
power in their jaws is amazing and if I
keep quiet you might be able to hear it
crunching down on the bone you can see
it salivating because it's trying to get
to that bone I'm not sure if you'll be
able to hear it is a little soft but
basically what it's trying to do it's
trying to basically get any little last
bit of nutrients that cancer it's kind
of biting down on the leg bones and and
the sort of areas where there's a bit of
maybe marrow that's exposed and can try
and feed off that so you'll see this
little hangers they'll come back day in
day art especially after a bit of rain
rain basically reactivates the scent a
little bit and it makes everything kind
of smell like there's a fresh wall at
least some meat left and then they come
in and they come and chew the bones and
they scatter things around and they'll
choose the skin so is still some
nutrients left Jeff for both vulture and
hyenas there's a few vultures that are
here as well there's a white back
Fulcher that's off to the right hand
side that's feeding off the spinal area
and then in the distance there's a whole
bunch of hooded vultures that are
sitting up on the tree over there so
there's four hooded vultures all
together
hoping maybe just maybe there might be a
Egyptian vulture amongst them but alas
no sign of our Egyptian friend
on this carcass which is very very sad
Sisi the smell is almost non-existent
now is no real smell kind of decaying
dead dry smell but it's not nearly as
bad as it was a few few weeks ago
once all the meats really gone and it's
just the bones that are left now the
bones themselves will stink this skull
and and the ribcage and everything else
he's going to smell horrific for months
and you'll take probably six months to a
year before you won't be able to smell
that dead decaying smell on the bones
but in terms of us just sitting here
it's not bad at all it doesn't really
stink much anymore it's actually quite
fine just sitting here not really
getting any smelling like that
so MIG sometimes they wag their tails
when they're happy they just just pins
on how they feel sometimes they'll just
kind of give it a little wag just
because they have fun and they like to
do it
no not really no honey knows when
they're excited will turn their tails up
so the tails will lift and they'll
become very excitable then they tails in
the air quite straight and they kind of
had them up in they and there's lots of
weeping that goes on with that but in
terms of when they see that each other
not really tell tends to stay flattened
down anytime we really see the tail
wagging as if they've got a situation
where they've got flies that are landing
on their coats or landing around they
really ended like that and then you just
see it kind of flicks to be able to try
and kind of chase them away but they
don't work them to be happy they they
are not a dog remember that they might
look like dogs but they are not a dog
they're in their own family altogether
and in fact they reckon there are more
closely related to cats in there are
dogs which is pretty interesting but
they are not a dog in any way so wagging
of the tail is not the same as a
domestic dog that's all for Hannah's
Jason I mean suppose there's a little
pale it's more of a gray color than some
of the other I in as we get but hyena
coats very massively I mean we know that
in the mara printhead those leucistic
hyenas the ones that had that were very
very white or very very light in Holland
and then you get ones that are very
ginger others that are a bit more gray
like this so it's I mean it's common to
see you know different sort of colors on
heiner's and this particular gray kind
of brown color is regular you see it's
often on hyenas many of our hyenas have
that kind of coloration young individual
you can see its spots or bright bright
bright they still very deep rich kind of
dark color few little wounds on the back
as well and then you see someone's bits
in it on the back and on the spinal area
maybe had a fight with another I know
and then also its ears are very very
clean so you can see the ears are not
too torn up is only an indication of a
younger individual but look hearts are
still trying to force its way through
that bone it's amazing the damage that
they can do in the power in those jaws I
mean that elephant bone is huge it's not
a small bone and you can see look hard
scrunch down you can actually want to
see the teeth marks on the edges of that
bone as they're going in and trying to
feed off it's amazing isn't it
incredible how efficient our cleanup
crews in the bush are you would think
that an elephant carcass would have
lasted for as for kind of much longer
than it did but when you look at it now
and you remember thinking of that
massive sized animal that was here and
you think about what we're seeing now it
is seriously incredible of what's gone
on there's very very little left Jen you
give it another week or so and there'll
be probably nothing nothing nothing and
most of these bones will be sprayed
apart the amazing thing is the skin is
to my right sort of back of the calf
when I first drove in I thought maybe
somebody had dropped a blanket but there
is the skin that is kind of just lying
next to the car over there doesn't it
look blanket like it does and that is
all elephant skin that is kind of
softened up now now that would have been
hard and almost crispy when
the Sun was out for those few weeks that
this was dead didn't have too much rain
but now with the two sort of storms that
we've had this skin has all become soft
and pliable and you'll find that that is
the perfect chew toy for hyenas and I
wouldn't be surprised that we see if
there's some hyenas here that maybe
potentially have young ones that they
dragged off bits of the skin back
towards the den sides and the reason why
I say that is because they will have a
situation where they can then the little
ones can chew on it and basically go
after it as much as they they want and
kind of swallow down those nutrients and
especially if they're teething it's very
very cool so know you're asking if hyena
clans asked the young males
well the males in hyena clans are
generally lower than low I'm wondering
why I was hanging that keeps looking up
into the tree and being quite nervous I
thought maybe just had a quick look in
their trees to make sure there wasn't a
lipid sitting here and we just
completely missed it but it definitely
isn't maybe something in the wind
because the wind is blowing over it's a
right shoulder of it
so how you know clans are the low I mean
males are the lowest of the low and so
yes sometimes look at the strength in
this look look watch it's dragging the
whole leg amazing so the males like I
said all those sort of own so it's often
that they kind of get chased or art and
they golf on their own and they go drain
other clans and they kind of move around
quite a bit but they don't in terms of
being ousted there will be sort of
competition amongst the males for sure
to be the top male but within the can
itself they are not the dominant force
and so they don't really get ousted by
the females the females are already
bigger than them stronger than them and
they just fall lower than their then the
females are in any case so it's not
really that they get a stood by the clan
itself it's more another male try and
asked an older male to try and be their
sort of dominant male within the the
grouping that looks after that
particular clan all mates in that
particular clan but they not really kind
of territorial very sort of kind of
combative males like you would see with
male lions or
lipids it's a bit different with hyenas
anyway alright sit with the site in a
little bit longer see what else maybe
comes down it seems to be quite nervous
so maybe something else is coming around
it is another eye you know actually
coming that's right so there's a right
in front of us that's just arriving as
we speak so just coming down the pathway
there we go hello a little bit more
ginger in that that's particular
individual so I'll just search and see
maybe more hyenas are going to arrive as
we kind of spend some time and while we
wait for this Hina to move in let's send
you back across to Steve who I believe
is at a dam yes we are indeed we are at
tree house dam and in the picture you
can probably see a beautiful little
sedge and sedges are quite easy to
identify by the fact that they have
edges I know that might sound a bit
strange but if I if you look at the stem
over here you see that there are
actually four sides to it so very easy
to remember trees have leaves grasses
have arses which might sound quite
strange and sedges have edges and the
reason why we say cross devices is
because there's holes in the bottom and
that's a grass there and a sedge has got
edges and they've got this very
interesting sort of leaf structure
always three at the top coming off but
the edge is very very cagey I don't know
which species of sedge this is there's a
couple of them down here by the river or
by the pan and sedge is a very good
indicator of moisture soil moisture and
very obvious along the edge of treehouse
dam and lots and lots of other edges
down here and you can actually make all
sorts of things out of sedge this is
almost related to to papyrus papyrus is
a type of sedge and as you know the
existence of humankind as we know it it
was written down on very very old
papyrus that was formed in Egypt very
very long time ago and that's how we
remember and transcribe everything
that's happened over three
years ago fantastic all started with the
little sedge and that's where human
history as you know it began but what we
have also found on by the water here is
evidence of what the Bushmen will talk
about and if we have a look in the dung
of this animal and the way it's been
spread out it's very clear that there
are no fish bones inside here and we
know that this is from a hippo and it's
quite fresh it smells quite fresh
it looks quite fresh so it must be quite
fresh and the the Bushmen talk about the
story I've told it before about how the
hippo lived in the water with its big
mouth and if you eat all the fish so
they need to come on to the land every
night and spread after dung and then God
will come along or the Creator and he'll
have a look through for any fishbones if
there are any fish bones he'll condemn
him back to the life he had before out
of the water
so hippos are definitely grazers and
they have the ability to digest or at
least ferments the grass at their feet
but it does come out very poorly
digested look at that look how poorly
digested that is it's almost nothing
taken out of there less than 40% of the
grass in hippo done is digested so ash
has anyone come across a traveling
crocodile on bushwalk I have not here in
rumor but I have many times before up in
the Kruger National Park right up in the
north we found tracks of them and we've
also found them physically walking it is
quite an eerie feeling and quite a crazy
experience your whole body just you just
freeze on the spot because there's
something about their crocodile that
makes you just want to stop moving and
also want to run away the other
direction but often they're just moving
back into the water or they crossing
land from one paddle to another
instinctively they're know as the dry
season gets more dry that dams like this
are going to sort of deplete in the
water and they'll go somewhere have
permanent water resource I hope that
answers your question I'm going to go up
onto the dam wall and see what other
activity there is there's not too many
signs of animals down here by the
water's edge but it is quite difficult
to really see in this hard soil
Gary I wouldn't say we've got
underground rivers but we do have
aquifers so there are huge water tables
underneath the surface all across the
country and that is in every country
actually and they're not flowing I
wouldn't say they're flowing but they're
all connected to the water table
throughout the continent or throughout
sort of southern Africa I'm sure you
find them all over the place and that's
one of the reasons Cape Town is having a
bit of difficulty with waters because
they planned a very long time ago a big
what would you say a rubbish dump on top
of one of the biggest aquifers that they
have and so all that rubbish seeps in to
the water that they have and they've got
plenty water but they can't use that now
problem problem problem problem planning
is very important when you're going to
develop a civilization they should have
read the transcripts on the Egyptian
Scrolls that they're rotes on the
papyrus 3,000 years ago and figured out
the importance of planning and human
waste and all our waste so that we can
have suitable water for drinking but
unfortunately as humanity appears to be
getting smarter we are in my opinion
getting a little bit more stupid as we
go has all been done before but yet we
think it is all new and we need to
reinvent it let's go to someone who is a
bit who has invented most things
Brent Leo Smith well unfortunately looks
like those in comas are in one of those
areas we cannot get a car we've checked
around so now we're just doing a quick
scan see if we can find any sign of
Tandy hopefully she's might make an
appearance if nothing we're gonna head
towards the west and check the sort of
northwestern corner we did have some
just so there was rain last night and
but we can't find any sign of the lines
moving I'm just double-checking and also
this is where Tandy was last sort of
seen was hiding was in this area same
area where the Lions are so she might
have moved out when they moved in
now you'd say it's quite cloudy not
foggy yesterday morning was incredibly
foggy at granny pig so this is just some
low-lying cloud it is relatively normal
for this time of the year winter unless
normal and winter we will get that mist
in the early mornings and then generally
clear skies during the day we will get a
few overcast days during winter but
mostly it is clear skies for most of the
winter months it's quite interesting as
I've been moving through the different
areas so the area around Camp got a lot
more rain last night than this Eastern
Area so it got a few drops but but not
nearly as much as we seem to get in the
center and the west of the reserve
they're quite interesting and our rain
can be very localized Archer as those of
you who watched us and tomorrow I mean
you can sometimes you can drive around
the storms to not get wet
initiate their cake little rattling
sister killer so in that little zone
that Buffalo woman I said he's
disappeared that way
you went down into the grass
ah let's see what what do you think
about the unicorns Tim because dot dot
dot Scotland I suppose that is a viable
of a viable one
haha now Eddie's on to a sort of tract
because it would make the crown is in
England mad so it actually comes from
medieval times when the Scottish and the
English were warring but it wasn't the
reason why it wasn't to make the crown
mad although that would have been a bone
a bonus added an add-on to okay we're
waiting now let's see if anyone's got
this
so you're spot-on be truthful that the
unicorn was used on the Scottish coats
of arms in the Middle Ages but there's a
very specific reason why it was used and
that's what I'm looking for let me see
what else you got
well Dan Laura well Dan you are correct
Lauren
so in mythical in mythical beliefs
unicorns are the enemies of lions and
can kill lions and the emblem of the
British crown which was trying to invade
Scotland and take over Scotland at those
times was of course the British lion so
that represents the crown of England and
the English king in the English ribs
into the English so the unicorn was the
animal that could kill the lion that is
why it is the Scottish national animal
yeah a bit of interesting folklore there
now there's no there's no sort of
unicorn equivalent art in Africa but
we've got some incredible mythical
beasts that are said to live in Africa I
think my favorite is what is the Coulee
Kumbha Oh
Coulee combi is a very specific mythical
beast to a certain part of Central
Africa and Gabon in particular and to a
certain tribe they're called the me na
and the Kula combat isn't bipedal ape
man and something crossed between a
gorilla chimpanzee and a human being
that is said to live in the forests that
surround the furred invaders the goon so
and we go Cooley combi he's a mad
Frenchman out there who believes in the
Cooley combat and he was trying to
convince me the one day of the Cooley
cumbers existence but he got his anatomy
class a bit mixed up because he was
mixing gorilla and chimpanzee bones to
try and make this thing that stands up
so yes it was it was it was an
interesting conversation and the more
you argued with him about that he was
mixing up the vertebra from a chimpanzee
or
from a gorilla on a chimpanzee a you got
more angry with you so to be friends we
just decided to stop arguing with it
Oh shucks okay so so zoom in center
frame where you were a little bit to the
left I get in that little acacia there
zoom a bit more little bit down he's
just behind that branch there let's have
a look you should pop out in a second
and he's just in there that's we landed
and I didn't see him fly on let me just
try it move forward a little okay just
keep an eye see if you see anything
jumping just try see if we can have a
look behind and could have hopped up
into those thorny thickets when's he
carried on there are one of the more I
flew done it he flew out of the tambuti
I said they're difficult ones to get on
camera but said this Frenchman I'm not
gonna mention any names
he eventually collected all his
chimpanzee gorilla concoctions
in this garden and sent them off because
no one would listen to him he paid a
huge amount of money to send them off to
Paris to an anthropologist and he came
to the same conclusion as the rest of us
it is a combination of gorilla and
chimpanzee bones not a new upright
species of bipedal eggs that has been
hiding in the third and vast
another one is McCollum member mcaren
been there is another Congo forest story
about this massive thing that makes
massive noises that lives in Lake tell
in in in the DRC and what is the leak
liquids look for McCullen bender we're
pretty sure we know what McCulloch and
Bender is now it's just a very very loud
Linda's not a very large slender snouted
crocodile I worked with a guy up in
Gabon is the leading expert on reptiles
that's not something you see very often
Archer
it's the Torchwood staff going home
obviously they don't have any guests
this weekend but so it's just from the
sounds and stuff it's nail so that this
spend slender slender started crocodile
makes a huge amount of varied screams
and noises I'll see if I can find some
sounds of it fee and when that's one of
the theories that it's especially there
in a very wet area there's quite a lot
of big slender snouts in that area that
it's a legend probably started and based
off the noises and whatnot that come
from the malenda snorted crocodile
anyway I'll see if I can find you some
of those sounds that they make and you
can actually get them to make the noise
if you tap the side of your boat they'll
start roaring at you sometimes that's in
the meantime it's going to the animal
who has a deal with the Nile crocodile
according to zoo D Zulu folklore the
water back well Brent II I can imagine
that heels that go on and on and on
about mythical stories all day Bentley
labs a African tale or mythical story
and will tell anybody who's willing to
listen so I'm sure he's got many but
what we've got is probably three of the
cutest fluffiest warmest animals this
morning with three of these little baby
water back there all together
surprisingly enough there is
not a single adult that I can see
anywhere near these three so why they're
on their own I have absolutely no idea
and why they would be kind of sitting by
themselves in this area is pretty
strange generally water buck of the size
are very close to mom and so I'm
surprised to see them all on their
lonesome but how cute are these little
guys look how fluffy they I would
imagine sighs and he says all the girls
in AFC are doing and eying and making
cute sounds I'm pretty sure that it
would be the case I didn't think
anything differently and know how the
girls and FC catch over these little
guys but they are very cute this
probably some of the cutest animals that
we actually have our chair now
they need to be careful they can't walk
around like this by themselves because
otherwise they are a prime target for
the likes of Tenggara and husana both of
which would probably love a water bug
snack and so they need to be a little
bit more careful about what they're
doing because if they're gonna sit out
in the open like this by themselves with
no adults they are going to make
themselves a target for any of the
predators that we get archer so things
like wild dogs even lines if they see
this will take well it wouldn't even
second-guess the chance to go after one
of these guys so they need to be careful
and and all likely would need to find
their mothers and the adults to be
careful to try and stay safe because
like I say if they stay like this
they're going to get themselves into a
lot of trouble but they really are cute
they're they probably got to help be one
of the most cutest animals in there baby
and mean any baby animal is cute but
these guys just because I've have
fluffier they are I think is what makes
them kind of appear almost teddy bear
like in a way very very cool now the
reason why I worry for them is because
we are chipped a damn wall and we know
that Dingaan and husana generally I
never far from this area and so they aim
to have a tough time of it if those two
boys are around and I'm hoping that
their moms are just down below the dam
wall and that's why they haven't kind of
stretched too much and it's why they're
just kind of standing I suppose they've
also positioned themselves probably not
too bad they kind of got Heights up
there it's gonna be very difficult
for husana or Tooting garnets who try
and hunt them unless unless they're one
of them can get behind this little wall
where they might walk down and he they
can grab them but your right knee is
very cool to see how different the
colors are even though all three of them
are of a similar size and age they all
have a very different look about them
you can see the smallest one is the
darkest one and then you've got a more
kind of rusty color on the left and then
that more normal watercolor on the right
so as they get a little bit bigger so
they start to kind of fade a little bit
which is opposite to a lot of the other
young animals a lot of other younger
animals start off quite lights and then
darken up if you think of wildebeest in
particular in sable as well they start
off more this color and then they end up
going into this kind of dark grays and
blacks that you see so interesting kind
of difference between them but how cute
is that and the little tail as well
Nicky the reason they array wagging they
tell so much is because of flies so as
flies are landing on them so they
wagging their tail to get rid of them so
they're getting irritated and flies
often congregate around the rear end of
antelope species so unfortunately for
them they get a lot of them and Nicky in
final control which is not the same
Nicky that asks the question it's all
getting very Nicky confusing at the
moment says that you can actually see
the flies flying about all around them
so that's why they wagging their tail
and making sure they get rid of them
doing a good job there little one your
tail is very very active and is
definitely wagging at a good rate
caryl they potentially could outrun a
lipid that's if they see a lipid coming
remember these are young young animals
these guys have got very little
experience and are probably on the side
of where they just don't really know
what's going on too much they that they
could easily be caught by a wily old a
cat like tungare I mean he'd be able to
force them into areas where it would be
easier for him to hunt but if if they
saw a lipid coming year sell out run
it's already at this age they already
probably have more stamina then a lipid
could have over long distance but the
problem is is for them is that they're
very vulnerable because they are small
and they are little and they're
inexperienced which means that things
like lipids that's exactly what they're
looking for they like to find small
inexperienced animals on their own makes
life a lot easier the only saving grace
is that they group together in a little
herd you wish an adult would come by
meet you I would be nice to have the
adults with them you never like to see
baby animals all on their own the
interesting thing about this is owner
Steve told me the other day that he saw
one female with four young ones now I
wonder if that female who has a young
one currently these three have not just
tried to latch on to that female to try
and kind of you know have some semblance
of security and that females now kick
them away and to go and find their own
moms but I promise you that there is not
a single water bike outside of these
three anywhere that I can see here
nothing on the open area nothing that is
kind of hanging around that I can see in
the thickets maybe they down below the
dam wall at the moment and that's why
the little ones are quite chilled but I
would have thought that with us arriving
these are the ones if the if the adults
were around would have gone straight
down towards where they are and to try
and kind of stay safe but it seems as
though they're not really sure when
you're first gotcha they're actually
lying down just on the left-hand side I
didn't really notice them until one of
them stood up but they were just lying
off the side of the dam wall by
themselves and like I said no adults
present so a bit of a strange one I
don't know what would have caused all
three of them to lose their moms maybe
something like wild dogs or something
separated the herds and they just
battled now to try and find where their
moms
and they've now it's kind of in a
situation where they lost but a mother
what's back generally is very good at
trying to kind of find her youngsters
and to make sure that she can see them
and and look after them so I just want
to double-check down here but I don't
see anything
so Lorna they do have very pointy tracks
in fact you wanted to know about their
tracks let's just go back because
there's some really nice water bug
tracks behind me here just give me two
seconds all right don't wash the way of
the tracks oopsie didn't really think
that through very well but here we go so
these are warts bug tracks on my
right-hand side that are walking along
there so reversing through puddles of
water where these tracks are never a
good idea but there we go you can see
that it's it's maybe not quite as pointy
as some of the other antelope species we
get yeah but it still does have quite a
sharp point in a very raised Ridge area
in the middle so you'll see that this
track can be confused sometimes with a
Valda B's track but I finally the Valda
B's track the back in splays a little
bit more and the mound of sand is bigger
than what you see on this particular
track in the middle section so that's
what about its now I'm just trying to
listen to me because somebody just
mention something sorry about station
just go again
so I'm just listening to the radio okay
copy
what's the honorably
right so we just got the news that I was
looking for and hoping that we would
find there's moms you see you know
that's dad over there is the male is on
that side maybe that's why they were
looking at him the male's just sitting
on that little sort of area over there
but we are going to try and me and our
way to something that we were hoping we
would find in this particular section of
the world and so while I do that it
sends you across to Steve and Ernest
ones how surprising what could it be
I bet shooting Ghana is sitting around
close by licking his lips at the thought
of a young water buck for breakfast but
we stopped here for a purpose of once
again the buffalo grass is growing out
like this we've got the Buffalo thorn
growing here and very unassuming in the
back there we have got the nest called a
woven nest of a blue wax ball and as we
approach the adult flew out of there and
they will use these nests obviously not
only for breeding but they were also
roost in them in the cold winter nights
to come because I know we were talking
lots about migratory birds on the blue
Expo is not one of them it's a small
finch like bird seed eater and they use
the grass not only for feeding on the
seeds of the grass but also for weaving
a little woven ball nothing like that of
a weaver they will just take a whole lot
of grasses if I can just demonstrate I'm
not the best weaver in the world and
they will just roll them into sort of a
ball lots of them roll them like that so
it's not much of a weaving as opposed to
a just a ball so that is a very nice
unique nest for the Blue Expo and his
put his nest in a very inaccessible tree
to try and get my hand in it and be
quite sore because there's lots of
buffalo thorn sharp hooked and straight
thorns there which is a very good place
for it's a secret itself away and to be
unavoidable every one because you
even see it Herbie with his eagle eyes
spotted that as we walked past and we've
been on the topic a little bit about
soil and geology this morning and that
previous rock I showed you which I said
was Granite's not actually granite rock
it is the breaking down of a granite
rock where's here is an actual granite
rock is very very hard very hard and
it's made up of a few different types of
minerals namely courts as well as mica
which is fool's gold and then felt spa
feldspar is the pink sort of little guys
in there the the quartz an example of
this this is a much larger quartz
crystal and we find these as quite a
dominant sort of chemical or or mineral
component of granite okay so very very
hard rock doesn't break down very easily
even though he did see a little bit
breaking off there as opposed to the
bath salts which breaks down very very
easy we don't find many basalt rocks
left just the derivative of the soil
that they leave behind so that is it
beautiful quartz crystals very nice and
big and the size of the crystal is the
term bar where it cooled in the
landscape so if you came up from the
bottom surface you came from the magma
deep down in the Earth's crust and
here's the surface of the earth and you
came up to about there and you cooled
down the cooling is very very slow so it
leads to very large crystals but if you
explode onto the Earth's crust in the
form of lava and you land on the Earth's
crust imagine going from magma which was
in the Earth's mantle which is extremely
hot molten rock and you land on the
surface as a rock you cool down far
quicker than you would if you're
underneath the surface though so the
crystals are much smaller and leads to
much softer softer Rock which is much
easily a withered and broken down so
that is a good way of working out the
difference in your basalt and granite I
do enjoy my rocks we don't find too many
rocks around here because it's all still
very flat and the weathering has
happened so I don't find too many
beautiful rocks mmm
Lady Bird I am not sure on what type of
gemstones be fine around here further up
in reserve called the salaat II who I
used to work as action emerald mined
there and they have closed down for some
reason but there are still emeralds
within the rock and those have come
about from a process known or a
rock-type known as talc schist
or soapstone and there's emeralds
actually metamorphic crystal inside of
that metamorphic which was actually
basalt at one stage went an extreme
pressure like this and it changed the
crystals from whatever they were before
into emerald so they found emeralds
there I have never found I did to go
scratching around in the soil and the
rocks there but I didn't find anything
of any great value but in Botswana
there's lots of diamonds that are found
in and around in Namibia they're
diamonds found all along the coastline
there you cannot go into those areas as
you can imagine diamonds are quite
heavily controlled by the people who
have all the money but in this area I
don't know of any gemstones
unfortunately I can't help you with that
the birds are starting to wake up
they've been very quiet they've probably
been very wet just heard some Aramark
babblers making their very noisy call in
the background ok Tristan has found
something let's go and see whose spots
he's looking at hoping to come and find
it chatter so he's hidden a little bits
at the moment he was up in a tree and
came pounding down as we gotcha
and then darling to the grass wait he's
now lying completely obscured so I'm
horse on I like normally he's a little
poser and his look likes to stay up and
kind of have a look I think it's because
there's lots of rutting impalas around
maybe decided would be better to come
down and lie in the grass but he's
sitting here because yes he has a kill
at the moment I can't see where exactly
the kill is but he does have a darker
kill somewhere in this area and just
can't see exactly where the killer
itself now if he lies down we're going
to see absolutely please nothing of him
it's really long long grass at the
moment and you can see this is typical
of the summer months is when the grass
gets long like this and we use kind of
come over and liquid almost disappears
and if you didn't know that he was
actually here you would have a situation
where he would probably have been driven
right past you wouldn't be able to
really see him now Mehsana what have you
been busy with interestingly enough when
I was crossing the dam wow so fun tracks
for ting garner quite fresh ones that
are sort of just at the end of the rain
and so he's also looking around this
little water bucket need to be very very
careful about staying in that area
otherwise they're gonna get themselves
into a lot of trouble but at this stage
he's no way to be seen ting Garneau
which is a good thing I suppose for a
son because he'll manage to keep his
kill that he has at the moment otherwise
he might have a situation where he'll
unfortunately lose it if ting garnet
does come along so indigo girl he has
been busy
husana is a busy cat we know that he
seldom likes to sit still and loves to
be hunting and moving around and trying
to find as much food as is possible
and so we see him kind of around and
moving all the time and he has been busy
as opposed to finding himself a little
dyke and I think he actually came off a
kill from tortured I know in Taylor had
him the other day with ting gana I'm
pretty sure he came out from tortured
and possibly had himself a bit of a meal
that he was then able to kind of deal
with but he's kind of looking up into
the tree I don't see the kill in the
tree itself which might be the reason
that he's down maybe just maybe he ended
up pulling it down and it's on the
ground at the moment but it's a very
obscure view at this stage
so Brittany husana means the little
chief or the little prince is the kind
of direct translation for it and he got
that because obviously his mom was ruler
who was the queen of German so it made
sense to call him the little prince the
little chief as well basically comes
from that lineage and as it's turned out
he is the default French he kind of
doesn't really care about anybody else
he just does his thing and he's an
absolutely epic cuts in his relationship
currently with you note in Ghana's
absolutely fascinating to me to watch
their kind of interactions that they go
through in Mehsana kind of walks up to
ting gan and just really doesn't care as
much as tink on it doesn't want him
around he just doesn't care he's forcing
his dad to almost be friends with him
and he does this with Tandy and he
doesn't he's done for Shadow and so he
seems to be a cat that almost likes
company and me seeing him follow around
all kinds of different animals so he
really is a little character and I
suppose if you are the Prince you're
allowed to do all of these things maybe
he's got that kind of thing way just his
mom says I can do it and so that's why
he did it
but he's a very cool cat I've thoroughly
enjoyed time with wasana
over the last year he's really given us
probably more than any of the other
lipids if you think about them I mean I
know we've had an amazing stuff with
tani and should do you and shadow and
then even Tenggara and her Kumari but if
you think about just the constant kind
of sightings that we get from this
particular cat we are really spoiled
he's given many many many insights into
leopards that many people probably would
argue with if you had to tell them that
had no experience of this particular cat
and he's also you know seems to just be
one of those cats that we see probably
more than all the others as well so he
really is a special individual and
whoever inherits him if he moves away
from this area is going to inherit a
very very special individual and going
to be very fortunate I I have a sneaky
feeling he's just going to be one of
those lipids that's just not going to
take this I have to go somewhere else
for you know as the rule he's going to
try and probably have a situation where
he's going to try and stay here for as
long as he can
from Italy you know dad is not really
pushing him away but Camrys seemed to
chase him the other day but it didn't
really affect us on how much if you
think about how hassanein literally just
went straight towards we kind of vocally
had chased him the very next day it
seems to see that he's not really that
kind of concerned with what goes on and
he's pretty happy to continue to be
around sort of Jame area so I think
hopefully he's going to stay I mean
obviously it's it's gonna be an
interesting one there's so much upheaval
in the lipid world at the moment and and
it could very well lead to him being
pushed on but he seems to have kind of
thought to himself that Chitra is his
and that he's going to take this in a
sort of southeastern corner of Jummah
for now so that's fine by us as long as
we get to see him I'll be very happy
with him taking over Chitra and even
maybe now and then popping on to Juma in
that southeastern corner interesting
that Herkimer he's told and hasn't
really kind of pursued Dingaan I mean
husana that much and also this new male
that we're seeing on little Gary how he
hasn't chased either ting on or or sawn
away just yet good well we're getting to
sit with him and and try and see maybe
he's gonna get up and move you know a
sonic sometimes doesn't always race for
long and while we do that to send you
back across to Steve who I think is
staring at one of well our ugliest
creatures we see our son idly Tristen
it's beautiful not as beautiful as a
sauna I must add but it is a slag blaze
gentlemen and what it's trying to do it
was moving across the road it's trying
to camouflage itself with little quartz
crystals from the granitic soils we've
been talking about isn't that marvelous
isn't that marvelous let's turn him over
the bottom side is the very sticky side
where it moves this is called the foot
of the bottom he's covered in in in the
gravel from the soil itself to three
Heights really see his mouth is over
here and they feed on vegetation they
are grazers very much like like a snail
itself and the chainsaw like a mouth
part so in there and as they move over
stuff there kind of vegetation that is
they sort of grind it down like a
chainsaw would do without the noise of
course
but he is quite sticky and quite slimy
and he was trying to move across the
road when we caught him trying to
camouflage himself with all of those
crystals I'm going to put him back there
IV in Culina yuck you say poor little
guy I'm just gonna put him back
not so yuck really just a little
creature doing his thing moving through
the environment and trying to survive
and it is nice and moist out there at
the moment which means it's easier for
him to move around much more difficult
to move around if you are a dry animal
they need moisture to sort of slide
across the ground so someone who's not
sliding Brantly Smith he's driving well
I've been trying to find a decent audio
recording of that cataphract Asst Missy
sup scatter factors Lane it's not a
crocodile roaring but I can't really get
a good one
but they get much louder and much more
scary than that that's the best one I
can find now there are quite a little
known species and quite endangered
through most of their Retton but they
all mean they fake it you can hear that
from sometimes a kilometer way and this
is and I think there's quite a lot of
theories now that the McCullough member
bear from Lake Tell is actually just a
really big and very loud male cat a
fractus saying it's not a crocodile
those of you who've watched the video of
our Ricky - conga there's some clips of
slender snouted crocodiles in that video
that we saw while we're traveling along
those waterways so now I'm quite I'm
quite like I think so there's different
subspecies of slender starters and dwarf
crocodile but of the main sort of
species of crocodile in Africa I have
caught by hand all while I've caught
Nile slender snot and dwarf crocodile
for various different reasons worked
with a guy up in Gabon is sort of the
leading world expert on crocodiles and
specifically Central and West African
crocodiles so we caught some some of the
Nile crocodiles that go into the ocean
in that area and swim quite big
distances in the ocean between different
lagoons to take little genetics skin
samples from them
same with dwarf and Angelina started
crocodiles and we even found some
Stander's snart's - crocodile nests so
it's quite interesting about your dwarf
crocodile and you'll standar started
crocodiles that occur in those congo
basin forests so Nile crocodiles and a
lot of the other crocodilian species
rely on open sand banks and stuff to you
to lay their eggs so the Sun can heat
heat them up and keep them warm and then
the said having different layers of sort
of sexes depending on the heat of the
nest so your females will come from the
bottom of your males from the top the
higher the temperature the more males
the lower the temperature more females
so that's a big problem where you get
exotic and
of plants coming into certain areas
because they end up turning the nest
all-female and you run out of males for
breeding now your forest crocodiles like
your your standard started and your
dwarf crocodile obvious of course living
in those closed forests it's near
impossible for them to find decent
breeding grounds if you had to have that
open sand bank
so how they've evolved to avoid this is
they'll build them what they need so
they make massive mounds out of leaf
litter and understand it's not a
crocodile sort of this big will build a
mound that's probably about sometimes up
to to one and a half to two meters in
size and of all the detritus and rotting
leaf litter and stuff like that and then
lay the eggs and the center of that and
the D comes decomposition of all those
leaves and sticks and and and stuff like
that creates heat so that's how they
keep their nest warm from the
decomposing vegetable matter that they
pile up around their eggs so very
interesting how they've evolved to
survive in those in those forest areas
their diet is also incredibly varied so
the big Crocs obviously need big things
to eat like Nile crocodiles there's
Linda's nuts couldn't really attack a
human being or anything like that their
nose is very small very thin teeth far
more needle-like then a Nile crocodile
so far more Peskov all made specialize
in fish and obviously insects and
occasionally the older bird or whatnot
but very seldom dwarf crocodile actually
their main one of their men diets
depending on where you are is-is-is
frogs and bats and stuff and they are
out of the three species the least water
alliance so they will build these
burrows in the forest and and underneath
eventually I'll get down to groundwater
so they have a pool their own private
pool and in their burrow
I've actually climbed down dwarf
crocodile burrows before to try to see
what's going on and as you do of course
now as he says how do they catch bats so
quite often well there's a there's a
whole population of them live in a
section of caves in in Gabon that have
actually become
sort of orange they've changed color
because they don't ever really got out
of the Batcave but in in the boroughs
that they live in the the bats will
actually some certain species of bats
will utilize their burrows and the
forest is a place to roost
so they'll fall into the water and
they'll eat them there but that crabs is
another big favorite of dwarf crocodiles
actually hunt the forest crabs quite
frequently so it's very interesting that
how the different animals are able to
adapt and evolve into different
environments now it's very seldom that
you find many slender snouted crocodiles
near where their Nile crocodiles because
the Nile crocodiles will eat the map so
in Gabon where you had all three species
in one area the Nile crocodiles were in
the big open water and the lagoons
around rats along the along the coast
the further inland you went and the
deeper into the forest where you left
all those you lack those big sand banks
etc your your standard snart's it would
be on the main waterways what is that
there do you see what I'm looking at
okay I think it's a termite mound
through the distance there you just have
a look at the Viners yeah it's a termite
mound unfortunately and then your your
dwarf crocodiles actually live out in
the forest and they'll walk around and
in the forest some sort of farm or
terrestrial then the other crocodile
species okay well let's head you back to
Stevens found something that's creepy
and crawly it is very creepy but it's
not very crawly at the moment in a very
hard to really keep it in frame because
it is not moving very well beautiful
caterpillar like stick I think
absolutely marvellous the camouflage
that this thing is practicing it's just
holding on with its front legs
well those its back legs I don't even I
think that's the head I'm not even sure
now I can see it look at those eyes we
think those are the eyes and there's the
body as you go back there's a false sort
of sticking
sticking off the top there look at the
legs holding on and then it's bottom is
in the air in a very sharp little
fashion I have no idea what this is
leather gentlemen if you by any chance
know what species this might be please
let me know some form of Caterpillar I'm
thinking otherwise it's a very
strange-looking stick I can't believe
how well it matches the actual branch
that it's on as well as on the branch of
a small white berry bush
no white berries on it at the moment but
it matches it beautifully it's almost as
if it was designed for this particular
tree itself and it is not uncommon there
are a lot of caterpillar species out
there that or larvae should I say the
butterflies that lay their eggs
specifically on certain species and then
those larvae or the eggs will hatch and
the caterpillars which are the larvae of
the butterflies will feed exclusively on
the plant that it has put on some of
them are over a broad variety of trees
and some of various species specific so
this one potentially could be a species
specific to the white berry bush
it is marvelous Patrick I do agree with
you take your screen shots and wind is
moving a little bit yeah Sophie I think
would go with that an alien caterpillar
indeed but how marvelous is that sort of
camouflage so if a bird was moving along
here I think it would find it very hard
to identify that caterpillar as a food
source
well marvellous thanks for that fig very
nice attempt caterpillar for us for the
morning definitely a creepy crawly well
it seems like Tristan might have had a
better visual of that young chief let's
go back over to him we do half bits of
visual is maybe slight exaggeration but
at least we can see more spots and at
least he's kind of back of his head is
visible but he's fast asleep at the
moment he's I think had probably a good
eat
and after taking his kill a pinch that
she and then bringing it back down again
for some odd reason you know Hasani does
these funny things I actually think he's
done it on purpose and normally what
happens is that electric will take a
kill into a tree and they leave it up
there and then they just go back up and
down but Hasan is clever is what he's
done is he's brought this carcass down
and he shoved it into the long grass now
fort in Ghana or Java or any lions that
potentially could be in the area it is
almost impossible now for them to spot
that carcass as opposed to if it was
dangling from a big marula tree in this
area if it was dangling from the tree
much easier for any of those are the
cats to spot it and to come to where he
is and feed off it he also knows that in
all likelihood there's going to be very
little hyena movement during the course
of the day so bring it down put it on
the ground where it's easier to eat it's
also out of the sights and out of the
way of marauding male leopards in the
form of Tenggara and then tonight if the
hyenas start to come back and take it
back up into the tree and race there's
at the end of the day the kill which I
can't see to be honest even in this long
grass I just have no idea where he's put
it I'll try and find it just now but it
Pena's a little Dyke here that he's got
he's kind of then put it in down and
right next to the base of the tree and
then he can just pop it straight back up
should he need to if anything arrives so
it's suppose it's very clever from him
and I wonder how he's learnt that
because he must have had it stolen at
some point for him to have that kind of
behavior Ramat I don't think her son is
really quite yet to be fighting for
territory and I think he's brave enough
and and kind of got this sort of
demeanor where he doesn't really care
about other life it's too much and kind
of just roams around and but I don't
think he's he's ready to fight with
anyone here I mean you still a young boy
everybody keeps kind of thinking of
asanas you know three four year old male
he's not he's only two and that's still
very small and so I don't think he's
gonna be fighting just yet I think he's
just gonna try and wing it as far as he
can without having to fight with anyone
the thing is though is that he's already
starting to get to the same size who can
where you say if he can just eat out
another year without being chased I
reckon he would be a serious competitor
to Haku Murray and to being able to
actually kind of chase him out of the
way so it'll be interesting to see I I'm
hoping husana can clean
this area and until such time as he's
big enough cats there are females that
potentially would be in the area for him
I mean we know kochava is here but she's
got a cub at the moment so he's not
gonna be mating with her anytime soon
and that's really the only female that
he's will be able to worry about at this
stage we have a situation where he could
possibly subbu you might push for the
north we might have other females
arrived but at this stage is just good
Java and there's gonna be interest
fronting on and quarantine there and
because she's got a couple to see she's
not in any sort of Easter cycle
whatsoever so it's you know at the stage
he's also not really going to be in the
situation where he's mating there are
males that have mated as young as two
and a half three years at the white
their male down in the south of the sabi
sands he's mated at a very young age but
I just don't see it with her son I don't
think he's right at that age he a tree
he can start mating and start actually
looking for for females to mate with
also theoretically we don't really want
him to be mating with cassava or Tandy
at this stage given that Tandy is his
sister effectively the same mother and
in kochava Stanley's daughter it's a
little bit incestuous
so hopefully you won't have a situation
where that happens hopefully he'll be
able to dominate and the likes of
shadaloo and Sibley and those females
come in and he can mate with those
instead but it's gonna be really
interesting is I mean you just don't
know what the outcome of what's going to
happen is there's just too many
variables at the moment to know who's
gonna be where in a month's time
everything could be different as it has
been over the course of this year it
seems that every month there's a new
lipid that shows up there's a different
sort of way of things going but mrs.
grumpy you suggesting a good female
companion for husana to matrice would be
should do I agree
I think should do would be an epic one
before her solid Tomatoes be a very
stocky liquid that's for sure that would
come out of there I still like the idea
of should you having comes with her
Kumari just from a point of view that it
would be fun to have the chicken
medicine and termite mound mate and then
we would have we could have the two Cubs
called
chick
mound and termite medicine and then that
would be perfect so it could be who
could do Lu in shimmery that would be
the Cubs so two covers is what she
should have and then we can have those
teaming obviously that's complete
nonsense we're just making it up and you
know the way things going but I mean
look I don't think Hassan is going to
push that for waste anytime soon
you know the last time he pushed quite
far north and west into Juma he met with
hooker Murray and obviously a chaser I
don't think we're gonna see much of him
with should delay is more likely him
going towards to be kochava and then
maybe any of their the liquids that
occur and in Torchwood Oh paddy depends
you know there's obviously times when
both of those options are important so
strengths and experience can be useful
in both situations I mean obviously the
stronger you are the easier it is but
experience was her help so you see
smaller male lipids if you look in mono
model there was a time when we had you
know the bicycle crossing male and a
couple of others and they bicycle
crossing there was not as big as maybe
some of the others and and we're still
able to chase often and get rid of a lot
of young males that came in that were
potentially physically strong over there
so it's sometimes I'm all about kind of
the the attitude and the experience that
they've had and the techniques that
they've had in hukum where he's a prime
example of this he's just stood up to
probably the biggest lipid that there
isn't the sabi sands currently in the
form of Anderson and he's come out
unscathed so he's attitude in his
experience which I'm sure Herkimer he's
probably got more experience in all of
the lipids that we've got in this area
in terms of males just given the amount
of distance he's traveled gives him an
advantage from somebody like asana who's
never really had to fight it hasn't come
across males that are very hostile
towards him so in his case experience is
going to be hugely important even though
he's not the biggest and strongest of
the lipids that we have our chair so
just depends on the individual depends
on on what lipids are around and like I
say what sort of experience they've had
in the last sort of war in their lives
at at that point so we'll just have to
kind of see how it goes I think Kumari
though it's going to have a situation
where
is not going to kind of be able to stand
up to some of the younger males that
might come through and that are bigger
so I believe a lot of you enjoying the
fact that we've come up with these it
was actually Andy that first came up
with the the who could do you and she
movie kind of names and like I say it
would be chicken medicine and termite
and know what I say this chicken mound
and termite medicine is ever said or
chicken medicine and termite I don't
know whatever we even either way it's
entertaining and it would be very very
funny to kind of see so I think chicken
mound and and and too much medicine
would be to cuter little Cubs from those
two so we'll just have to see how that
goes and and see whether or not that
happens I mean I looked at you the other
day she doesn't look pregnant to me she
might be she might honey I have one but
it really if she mated when she did
which was early February by now I
suppose that was the second mating I'm
always thinking of the mating in
December which would have shown by now
but maybe her second round of mating in
February it's possible especially if
she's only got one cub you know we only
a month into that and so he's very
difficult to see any signs that a month
it's only around two months that you
start to pick it up and if we think of
Tandy when we started to see her we kind
of called that she was pregnant maybe a
month out from her giving birth it was
the first time we noticed that she was
pregnant and so when it's one cub it's
difficult and maybe it should you lose
pregnant but it's very difficult to say
at this stage it doesn't look like it to
me
but we'll see well see how it goes she's
have not been in East recycles and she's
not really been mating much over the
course of the last month so maybe she is
and maybe she's kind of just much
showing just yet because normally with
females when they at that age they're
young like that they are often into
their Easter cycles every two to three
weeks and mating excessively to try and
fall pregnant so it'll be interesting to
see what happens right
well little hasana is napping he's
taking it very easy at the moment and I
don't know if we're gonna see much
movement from him but we'll give it a
bit longer so while we do that it seems
you I think like Ross did Brent and see
what he's been up to
well chatting about should do Louie in
an area where should you likes to
frequent and so does look amore so maybe
in this nice cool morning we might find
one of them making it easy for us and
just strolling down the road in the
meantime while we keep checking this
area we can chat a little bit more about
mythical beasts ok did you know of any
mythical African animals no ok so
there's quite an interesting myth that
permeates through quite a lot so he was
talking about lions there I'm just
couldn't hear him clearly anyway so um
it goes through quite a lot of the in
greeny tribes and that is of a great
snake that lived in a hole in the ground
and this great snake was a banana it was
a god actually more than anything else
it was a bit benevolent God it possessed
great wisdom and great healing powers
and the story goes as the great chief
became very ill and he had four sons and
he sent the four sons to see the great
snake to get some medicine to help him
in the first and oldest son went and the
snake gave him the medicine said you
must be very careful you cannot spill a
drop otherwise it won't work and you
must just be careful and he said
there'll be many trials and tribulations
on your trip back to your father end
Wolfie went with the the medicine and a
male lion popped out of the bush and he
got a fright and he smelled the medicine
everywhere and he came back crying to
his father that he had failed and second
son went the same story trials
tribulations black mamba reared out of
the grass sports all the medicine and
also the snake said you can't come back
come back once you've been
and then the third son was nowhere to be
found
so the fourth son went same story trials
and tribulations and whatnot and was
tripped up by the the third son and then
the third son went and tried to kill the
great snake and the great snake decided
that human beings were evil and just
shut up shop and the chief died and it
turned out the third son had been
poisoning his father to try remove him
and then he had planned to poison his
brothers so the great knowledge and
healing powers that the snake held on
our loss to the human race forever
that's quite a common one it stems
through quite a lot of Africa there's
different versions of that one one of my
favorite ones comes from just north of
yet in Venda the land of moojiji the
reign queen and there's a lake they
collect full don't doozy
and it is very sacred like you can't
form it you got to get special
permission to even go near it and it
said that they are evil water sprites
that live in that lake and there lots of
different sacrifices are made to majazi
the rain green and to the water sprites
and stuff at that in that leg now the
water sprites have long sharp canines
that rip people's throats out but they
are half day and a half night so if you
look straight on to the leg during the
daytime they approach you with their
dayside that mimics the mimics the day
and they kill him and drink your blood
and if you approach and look at the lake
during night they approach you with
their night side that mimics the night
and they kill you and drink your blood
so when you go to give your
sacrifice or or pay homage whatnot at
Legg funda newsy there is only one way
and this is not a joke this is true that
you are allowed to look at Lake funda
newsy and I'm going to show you but it
is quite ridiculous so you're supposed
to walk up to the lake like this not
looking at it and then the water sprites
to leave you alone and once you get and
you want to look at the lake you
actually have to look through your legs
and then it is said you can see the cuts
between the day and nights of the water
sprites so you could kill them if they
came up to you
so you don't and so they don't there's a
lot of really really cool folklore from
vendor which is some of it's quite
fantastical so it's actually a very
interesting story that and the vendor
also have the the folklore of Arts
Giants now the area where the vendor
live north of yet is proper bear Bab
country there are many many many bear
babs and it is said that they are
sleeping giants and if they're ever
working
they will wipe out people say and I
think it's quite a story quite often
used to scare small children and bathing
like lots of fat cause originally where
Red Riding Hood etc so yeah so there's
quite a lot of interesting interesting
folklore around
I'm just trying to remember when another
one of my favorites now of course
there's a lot of folk laws that rely
solely on animals not only on people but
in while hassanis heads up let's go have
a look at him
well his head is up because decided to
groom himself and you can see his duiker
carcass is actually in these about to
start playing with it so he's got one
foot on the tree one foot on the carcass
and what he's doing I have absolutely no
idea it almost looks like brains trying
to look between his legs at the moment
so it's kind of it's infectious
apparently between our animals but
brains is also bouncing around and
contorting himself into interesting ways
and so hasanah and what son is going to
play with his carcass now he's decided
it's time I want to play around with my
duiker interesting as well is what
happened was we had a situation where
the male died kay actually came back yet
so I think this is a female duiker that
he's got over here and I'll I'll be
interested to see if I'm right and the
reason why I'm interested to see is
because often you'll see with dykey win
is when is kind of one that is killed
because they monogamous the other one
actually comes looking for it and very
common they actually get killed together
which is pretty weird
I know Tandy used to be a big exponent
of that she used to hunt families of
decay often on Jetta and so the I think
the male came looking for the female
spotted wasana and then ran away as
quick as possible but it seems like he's
rested long enough now and now he's
going to get into playful mode but he's
going to pull his duiker clock ass
around there we go you see it he's a
female it doesn't have horns you see
that so that's why the male was here
looking for his mate unfortunately which
is very very sad and it's just goes to
show how tight that bond is between
these monogamous antelope species you
would think when one gets killed that
they would just run away and leave it
much like what you see from things like
impalas in the max but as you can see
with with dykey and Steinbach they often
do come back and try and kind of see if
the mate is around it is kind of sad
isn't it it was tyranny and like I said
it's nature it's the way things go
Archer and I suppose Hasan has gotta eat
the thing is his belly is absolutely
massive already and it looks like he's
hardly eaten
so I wonder if he didn't have another
kill already sometimes what you will
find also in their feed or things like
this is that they have killed the baby
and they may the mother as well and and
so maybe he's eaten the young one and I
was eating the mother of this particular
individual we'll see now I mean he's
looking up into the tree again maybe
he's gonna play around and take the
carcass up into a tree we know he's a
playful cat so sometimes he gets these
kind of moments where he wants to play
around and especially when you've got a
situation when it's cool weather like
this he often is very playful
isn't he a beautiful boy though his
teeth are very white because he's young
so he's any like I said he just gone to
so his teeth are still very very white
in coloration they obviously will yellow
as he goes and if you compare it what
are you doing
Isana now he's on his back trying to in
the I don't know what he's up to this
cat is hilarious what are you doing boy
now there's a stick on your head now
what you can see that even though he's
gotten big and he's you know he's kind
of growing up and he's doing adult
things there's still this useful side to
us on and where he plays around was
branches like this what are you doing
boy our paws are in the air and on his
back he looks about as comfortable as
possible really is kind of another story
of this case and you guys yeah white day
tummies are you often forgive just how
white and lipids tummy is and when they
lie like this is actually quite easy to
spot them because of how bright they are
and in the long grass as soon as he
rolls over the other way it becomes a
lot harder to see so that beige
coloration as opposed to white blends in
a lot better there there we go that is a
leopard in total the kind of suppose it
is a Monday morning so he's welcome to
have a little bed rest and especially in
conditions like this what are you doing
mr. yeah I don't know I mean it's he's a
bit of an anomaly you see tumba doesn't
really spend much time rounding honor
you don't see many other and male if
it's doing these kind of things the fact
that he's following Tenggara around i
have no idea why he's doing it could be
that he lost his mom he could be that he
just craves company no sir could be a
situation where he knows that ting gana
often is a safety point and he's a
curious cat I mean it's not like he
doesn't have any approach to Ghana he
approaches everybody he approached even
who can where he literally walked
straight towards him so he just almost
is like he wants to kind of investigate
and see who all these other people that
look like me or other lipids that looked
like me I want to go and try and kind of
see everybody and make as many friends
as possible so he's just a curious cat's
it's the same as him following around
all kinds of other animals that we've
seen him follow in the case of Buffalo
that's a little bit different he's
learned that's potentially following
around Buffalo can result in food and
that's why it's following them around
but with other things that's I think
it's just more curiosity than anything
else that he wants to go and investigate
very impossible to say that's a question
where we just will never know had
crooler not disappeared would he be the
same way as years now no idea in terms
of an investigative cat he always was
even as a little cub he was one that was
quite active and went and saw things and
practiced hunting and chasing and so I
think he'd still be a very effective
hunter but whether or not he would have
the same demeanor I have no idea but
it's like I say impossible to tell but
isn't that awesome to see right well
Mehsana is kind of in between phases now
of playing and being awakened so we'll
sit with him for five more minutes see
what he gets up to because there are
others that want to come in this area
and if he does get up he'll stay a
little longer but while we do that to
send you back across to Steve who's
managed to find some rather large kitty
tracks
we have indeed we were walking along and
we in the Milwaukee drainage now and
here is the track of the young male line
you can see how far out those toes are
it's quite a big track it is in the soft
sand which makes it a bit bigger but
these are extremely fresh extremely
fresh they've come this way and they've
turned around again and we're gonna keep
going up this road following the track
see if we can find them
I've got a feeling there might be quite
close by by the activity in luck are you
feeling lucky is that the Dirty Harry
movie so let's just keep heading up here
they've just moved up this is a road
coming out of the mawashi called the
called Battaglia
kind of a Spaghetti Junction kind of
right in the middle well hopefully
they'll find a way to get a better
signal but husana as you can see has
gone into a position of recline and I've
seen this pose somewhere else before I
miss try and see if I can find a photo
of it but prints near Smith on the couch
and Inga's been watching rugby and then
he finishes watching rugby and falls
asleep this is pretty much what it looks
like just sprawled out over the couch I
once took a photo of it but it was many
many moons ago and I don't know if I've
still got it I'll have to have a look
just now but it's very funny when brain
falls asleep on their cards because he
just gets kind of exactly the same way
he's just on his back and there's just
limbs everywhere it's not a small small
person and the couch is not very big
either so it's always funny to watch but
anyway let's send you back across to
Steve I think he's got better signal
we're gonna keep we're gonna keep very
quiet I can see them just gonna walk up
there hopefully they don't get angry at
us I'm sure they'll be fine
they are quite a relaxed I don't foot
but we gonna be very quiet for the next
minute
can you see them this is fantastic
we've got lions and foot again now that
is the beauty about tracking and
understanding the freshness of tracks
and those tracks with very very fresh
and there they are
looks like one of the youngsters looking
at us they're probably about a kilometer
or two south from way I left them last
night and they're looking at me and
wondering if I'm food it's quite an
amazing feeling
so it's probably one of my favorite
things to find on foot his lines and
having an expert like Herbie around
didn't take us very long at all not far
from where they're being I fell in them
last time he hurts a little bit further
west from east from here but there
laughs coming in and out of this
drainage system yeah super excited super
excited everyone's excited as excited as
myself and her bein hopefully Ferg is
able to hold the camera steady looking
at us now
I can only see two here we can see a
third one but that's fine this is what
Lions on foot is all about started back
getting closer it's not about getting a
reaction it's about viewing them from a
safe distance where we're not going to
negatively influence them anyway
Franklin alarm calling behind us oh he's
just keeping an eye on them and on these
Lions doesn't matter how many times you
do this focus the heart rate always
increases by a huge beat staring down
the largest carnivore on the African
continent
with my stick there we go relaxed again
absolutely marvelous how's the visual
effect
you want to come up a bit closer a fake
Victoria you are excited and you would
be terrified but with people like myself
and Herbie you would make you feel right
at home but the beautiful thing about
being in the situation is that I'm not
thinking about anything else you're in
the moment it brings you straight into
the moment into the present it's just
the breath
that's the sounds it's the smell nothing
else is on the mind at all
and that is what's beautiful about being
in the bush you don't even have to see
these guys but the anticipation of a
seeing a dangerous animal effort does
something for the human spirit this is
where we as humans evolved this is where
we as humans spread ourselves out onto
the world stage on the African continent
in the savanna with lions with elephant
and to see them this close-up were
probably about 35 to 40 yards from them
at the moment it is always always or
inspiring for me
how's everybody feeling at home this is
fantastic
are you good Herbie he's completely
relaxed it's like a second nature to him
look at that
chilled there's a cucumber or is it as
cool as a cucumber African but that is
the marvelous thing foxes I can only see
to her beacon her beacon see a third one
but we know for sure just because the
Okuma pride is always together that all
11 individuals are some worthy in the
long grass and the visibility of them is
not great but this is fine renters on
his way here he's gonna be able to get
up a much closer and much more in
personal space with them cuz they're
much more relaxed to the vehicle and for
me it's awesome because last night you
saw we how close we were to the prod
themselves and how they were very close
to the prod or grab to the vehicle and
now we're 40 50 meters from there 40
times the distance but the sensations
coursing through me are far different
far more wild far more real and if you
ever want a true FA can experience you
need to get out on foot
laurits it's quite easy actually
how we exit from a place like this is
that we would just go back just back the
way we came we know where the danger is
we know whether the Lions potentially
asked if we wanted to leave here we
would just sort of back up and go back
the way we came to just go trudging
through there is just unethical we'll
probably chase the lions away okay so
apparently NYX is saying that we're
looking at the oldest female she's one
of the wound on her on her rump all I
can see is two sets of ears couldn't
tell you an individual from this
distance
apparently Ferg's managing to capture
the moment how's the steady hands
they're going well he's concentrating
focus I'll stop talking tip so they're
still looking quite interested you know
I mean they're up there there they're
paying attention to us I wonder how far
that could've went between them last
night at the end when they started to
finish in the kudu there wasn't too much
in the way of aggression that you
normally see when a a kill gets too
small it comes another line into the
frame from the side that's marvelous
so we've seen at least for now
let's just made my weekend thanks Herbie
very cool lions on foot is something
that if you've never done it before it's
something very very worthwhile doing I
mean the object of in it something I
always used to say on my trails is that
it's not about getting close we're not
that close but the feeling here there's
no there's no protection around us at
all so
good morning and a very warm welcome to
you all from wherever you may be in the
world we are coming to you live from
Drew MA in the sabi sands South Africa
where we have just found ourselves a
pride of lions on foot my name is Steve
Faulconbridge I'm joined by the very
steady handed Fergus who is managing to
do a very good job of looking at these
lions with the camera let's go back to
them and they're just lying up over
there please feel free to send through
your comments just below in the stream
let us know what you think about this
your questions this is the Inca Houma
pride we had them last night they killed
a kudu further north from where we are
right now
very exciting they're about two
kilometers south from where we had them
we were walking along we found their
tracks in the the River drainage
depression we did a bit of a loop this
way and that way with the expert help of
my very good friend here Herbie and we
found them within about three to four
minutes of the attempt trekking so that
is absolutely fantastic to be able to
see these cows on foot and this is live
ladies gentlemen these are wild lions
and they're about 30 to 40 meters away
from us right now
Cathy our absolute pleasure for going
live this is what we live for
and we're super excited we're able to
share this with you city your home or
wherever you may be the Lions looking at
us quite intently for a moment and but
now they're looking all over the place
they seem to be quite relaxed to Gary
and Craig from Australia welcome to the
show let us know what you think about
all of the seasons focus and my heart is
pumping in my chest Jesse this is
potentially quite dangerous but we are a
safe distance away and we are with an
expert by the name of Herbie he does
have a rifle in case of any emergencies
but we are walking as if we don't have a
rifle we're keeping very low our voices
we will not turn our back and we will
not go closer than this to influence
their behavior they are quite relaxed if
the Lions happen to go down flat and
their ears go flat and you
that you causing them some discomfort
but we're a safe distance away if that
did start showing us any warning signs
we'd immediately reverse and back out
with keeping our eyes focused on them
you can see that their heads are
starting to go down they are not too
concerned with our presence at the
moment our J we are being very careful
but thank you for the concern it is one
of the most one of the highlights of
being in the African wilderness is the
potential to walk and to encounter the
biggest carnivore on the African
continent on foot there is something
very special to be said about this kind
of interaction and there they go
they've gone back to sleep we clearly of
absolutely no interest to them
whatsoever
maybe we can creep up a couple maybe we
can creep up a couple meters Herbie
we're just going to go a little bit
closer figure just gonna keep his eye
peeled on these lines see sterling job
of holding that camera
and Jenna the in Kahuna pride has got
eleven eleven lions five adult females
and then six youngsters one of them is a
male they're about between ages of 14
months and 17 months so to speak
youngsters got its head up again it
hitters up again giving us a little
stare down how beautiful is that
good job Pegasus so ladies and gentlemen
if you are not there watching people
from California South Dakota New Zealand
so fantastic you're here watching with
us remember this is absolutely live and
if you'd like to continue watching
please we are still live on Safari lava
so please Google us keep watching the
show we'd love to have your support in a
net-net
have a fantastic morning
you're all back with us fixed
so before fergus's arm falls off and
before anything else happens we're gonna
go back over to Tristan Diggs he would
be back with us shortly
well well done guys on finding the Lions
they obviously had moved down towards
the Milwaukee and the signal issues on
the vehicles it's not an area that we
can check very often at all so Peters
saying goodbye to me at the moment so
Peter just left the sighting say it's
just saying advise pizza is full of the
joys of life this morning is being very
naughty on the other car and trying to
make me smile and miss a beat
while I'm talking to all of you but
we've got this down paths it's not the
first time that other guides have been
like this
but vasanas as you can see not really
been up to much he's catching flies now
as he does but I think he's gonna have a
bit of a nap he's got his kill right
pays doesn't really need to go anyway so
we're probably going to make way for
some others and and give everybody else
a chance to come and have a look at
what's going on but definitely got a lot
of meat still there he's gonna be yeah
for sure for the next day at least and
if he's not sure ting Ghana will be one
of the two of them will be on this kill
over the course of the next little bit
but we're going to head out three like I
say well give some others a chance
because also there's not very much space
to actually see him so if we move back
then it allows everyone else the better
chance of seeing what's going on
it's amazing the camouflage of these
lipids and how they can kind of blend in
if you didn't know that he was here the
I can guarantee you 90% of people would
drive right past cats anyway as we go
off let's send you back across to Brent
see if he's maybe had any luck with
cuckoo Murray or should do lute and see
if there's any sign of them on that side
of the world
while we've caught up with Steve and
Herbie and Fergus and just through that
gap there it's whatever lions are looks
like one or two of the might have
spotted Fergus is Ariel you can see that
one is looking quite intently at Ferg's
Ariel but we're gonna let the bushwalk
team have a chance to move out of here
safely there we go and we're gonna go
have a closer look at the lines mobs and
guys
they walked far from so they've from
where we looked for them this morning
they've come out on top of our tracks
and they've now probably covered about
two or three K's
okay look at this isn't this wonderful
hello Oompa Loompas
so let's see hi guys
- now Craig listen to me it looked like
one of the lionesses had a bit of an
injury try see if we can find it oh
they're all looking a lot better than
the last time I saw them last time I saw
them they were very skinny and looking a
bit bedraggled the moment they're
looking like very happy healthy Lions
surrounded ourselves with them so we've
got the majority of the the pride
sitting up there that's one of the big
girls there's another line is walking
towards her at the moment cakes and it's
just a little stretch by looking I'm
very happy come on pop out from behind
the bush I just want to see you can see
the females aren't too fat at the moment
I said it doesn't look like the biggest
could either aired last night this is
that the one with the injury doesn't
look like it
I'm very happy looking sub-adults
they're all around us and ones to the
left chair look particularly happy
there's a little boy
oh he's a little judge now he was quite
brave during the whole fight yesterday
warring and running around behaving like
he was twice his size as you can see the
Cubs have had a lot more to eat
look at those bellies
now where are you off to mr. this is
little male off to he's gonna go head
off to the rest of the pride
now bush walk of course was quite close
to these lines on foot and Andy the
danger isn't really from the Lions you
can't see during the day Lions have a
very healthy respect for human beings
human beings being the dominant diurnal
predator and they'll actually try to
avoid or run away from human beings
mostly and the brushroll cars were safe
enough distance that the Lions didn't
feel created so they didn't feel the
need to either run away or growl or
charge now most of the times that we
rely on charges it makes a lot of noise
and in doing that it's saying you guys
are too close go away but they don't
really want to get into a fight they
have their instinctively scared of human
beings during the day at night however
is a completely different story and they
would definitely try munch upon you o
next fatty is that scratch
a big lioness Lara and next to me at the
shoulder would probably be just below my
hip at the shoulder head probably just
above my hip my big lioness can wear as
much as 120 hundred and 25 kilograms you
off to go see the rest of the bride as
well with those wobbly bellies now the
last time I saw them they were looking
in not the best condition very hungry
very skinny well I got a few Nicks and
scratches as you can see but they are
looking far far better than when I last
caught up with in gormer's it seems like
they're really enjoying kudu at the
moment with the lack of buffalo around
they're probably not gonna move too far
today with those full bellies but they
might hunt again this evening now oh
sorry Greg now of course this little
male is not too old at the moment he's
hiding in the thickets eating some grass
Carol he'll hang around as long as
possible basically so normally to about
two and a half three years old three
years old normally they get the boot but
it's with the birmingham's
possibly not spending nearly as much
time here going forward he might hang
around a little bit longer
he might get get lucky but the females
will tolerate him for a certain amount
of time they do tend to get a little bit
aggressive when their sons on if you
start trying to mate with them but it
does happen especially if no other male
lions move into this area and he's able
to hang around till he's four or five
but that's that's very unlikely that we
would get no new males if the
Birmingham's decided not to spend as
much time here
now the voters would definitely try
claim this pride breezy if the bee boy
has decided not to come back however the
problem is they would probably kill all
the sub adults at this stage the females
probably need another year or two to to
really get to a stage where the males
would ignore them the young male however
would have to leave
regardless he would be there that the
voters would definitely try to remove
him from the equation completely oh here
we go got some movement again some a
little bit of groom all flopped down on
top of each other look at that lovely
little playing there practicing that
suffocation hold
oh isn't that sweet
it's still going for this the the
suffocation hold not really seriously oh
isn't this cute now lions are not the
nicest smelling things in the world Dean
fortunately at the moment after the rain
last night they don't smell too bad but
there are smelly creatures they eat
carrion eat rotting meat they're
predators yes they there they're not the
nicest smelling creatures are you going
to come across in the bush
now there's quite a lot of interesting
debates and research in to do female
lions prefer males with dark Mane's
which is what bear bob is asking as a
general rule it seems to be dark amend
males have more testosterone so are
slightly more dominant but again that
all depends on whether that males been
in a fight and injured and one of the
blonde demands males haven't so can they
can also disturb the the darker males as
the dominant in the coalition a male
lion coalition is a constant seesaw of
dominance but in in sort of controlled
captive environments it seems like
lionesses prefer males with dark men's
in wild environments it doesn't really
seem to happen because sometimes you've
just got a mate so as not to get beaten
up so I said it all depends on the
situation
now lovely to have asana and the income
is still on the property and hopefully
then it wouldn't have moved too far for
that sunset safari so I'm sure one of us
will be back to see what they get up to
you but from all of us here at Safari
Live see you in a few short hours for
lions and leopards galore